du tata steel ronde 12 je sais plus quel
rôle on est tellement tellement on a
fait des stream stoop merci à toi d'être
encore parmi nous je sais souffre
franchement bravo à toi ma performance
que moi je viens que week-end or c'est
pas si j'arrive avec mon grand sourire
tout ça sous pour essayer de gagner du
sob mais bats toi tu es là depuis le
départ grosse performance de souffle
avec un vexé stream même si tu es bien
accompagner un pôle dire t'accompagner
drôme inside en semaine de moi même le
week-end donc voilà c'est quand même des
supers conditions à ce niveau là mais
quand même c'est une sacrée performance
on peut le dire je vois déjà donné un
seul site où je sais même pas le temps
de dire bonjour bonjour a tous un mais
mais franchement impe et déjà un sobre
comme ça ça se fait pas ça se fait pas
c'est dur pour moi c'est dur pour moi de
me faire ça directement c'est moche
c'est moche c'est moche mais c'est comme
ça c'est comme ça
j'ai pas encore pris la parole manon
salut à tous et merci pour pour ce
premier seul cadeau je m'appelle prada
qui viennent battre du boeuf avec les
noirs
que moi même jamais gagné un seul aussi
faussement me tard elle à la map à
progresser ce tout pour débuter au début
je me dis c'est un bon client
franchement
au niveau des sables fins que tu me fais
aujourd'hui tu me l'avais jamais fait
cas regagna
qu'il faut que
le sens si peu salerno
c'est dur dur dur mais on va passer une
bonne après midi franchement ça fait
plaisir d'aller là où le délire du tas
da silva franchement alors demain demain
on peut le dire c'est pas le même
horaire parce qu'à chaque fois on prend
l'antenne à 14 heures et demain s'ouvre
c'est quelle heure demain c'est midi
mais me dit ça veut pas dire huit heures
pour chez toi c'est moi ça va être très
très tôt demain
assez bien ce qui me choque mais tu m'as
dit c'était quelqu'un qui est qu'ils
avaient bien travaillé le matin très tôt
non
non tenues avec m'a dit ça tu m'avais
pas dit ça j'ai un peu inventé
excusez-moi
[Rires]
souffre il a l'air il allait réveiller
je sais pas ce qu'il a fait hier soir on
n'a pas discuté ça hors antenne mai il
m'a l'air en forme le gall gastou fin
ouais je me suis levé à 7h30
on fait bomber maxx tous les jours je
suis mal à dormir et je la mange pas 3
lève tôt mais je veux être le noir
qu'est ce que mon mec qu'est-ce qui
t'excite com
comme parti aujourd'hui je pense parce
que d'un petit des rares
à paris on a chanté en kanaky
d'aujourd'hui donc hier il y avait un
petit air froid avec d'un partage
contenu proposé de prendre le bête de
savoir combien de coups à la dure du
parti
genre si sa venue au monde d'un coup par
ya un seul ou pas j'ai péché sais pas
trop
on a ensuite vu du convoi média 1 c'est
parti hp a été je pense
à la caréna carlsen
avoir avant la quarantaine qui a vu une
sicilienne
ouais et puis on peut dire qu'il a quand
même beaucoup jouer un homme n'ont
souvent qu'un en scène même régler nos
mains tout ça franchement c'était hyper
a une âme de la suivre en fait ok ça me
joue pas la dernière ronde si je compte
double of équipe de bouaflé mais c'était
trop vite donc on va être du wac forfait
exact de prague qui savent
mais en fait du couple dans la partie il
veut s'amuser il veut faire un bail ou
essayer de faire quelque chose parce
qu'avec eux 85 bon ok
peut-être qu'il a moins de chances de
cible de contrebalancer la partie donc
avec nous s'il n ya plus de chances donc
en tout cas je pense en effet de faire
aussi de prendre sa chance et donc on va
voir cas voilà qu'il subit un droit très
mitigé il fait beaucoup de gaffes dans
une beaucoup de parties ouais c'est près
d'une course car athènes essaie de jouer
là-dessus lui donc on va voir un seul
instant
qu'on a l'habitude de voir chez pas si
tu es d'accord se trouve mais c'est vrai
que non non c'est que c'est vraiment un
top player hyper fiable
à qui a été plus de 2800 donc ils sont
pas si nombreux que cela est passé plus
de 2800 bon là il est toujours tout
juste moins de 2800 mais là est il des
gorges un petit peu et c'est dommage
pour lui parce que pour moi c'est le
candidat le plus fiable à la couronne
mondiale actuellement de base bon là ce
tournoi ça va pas trop dans ce sens là
très clairement
l'arbre est à voir en tout cas
caronna c'est un joueur qui les rend
capables de tout et il peut
donc
vraiment voir
on est sur une roue solid le choix vous
voyez un peu un peu basique avec avec
les blancs et du coup c'est quand même
la partie normand qui s'annonce et la
plus excitante
et du coup avec cette vente c3 qui est
simple pour les blancs quoi il n'a pas
envie nécessairement de perdre je pense
aujourd'hui si je joue pour ne pas
perdre et ne perdra peut-être pas mais
il va pas non plus gagné contre
quinzaine comme ça donc on va voir les
prochains coups à être décisif pour
savoir si on va s'attendre à une
mondiale atteindra une partie fine qui
ou à l'or un truc un peu un peu plat
ensuite on a on a ici plein corapport
donc ça font partie intéressant parce
que les deux joueurs jouent assez calmes
assez offensif ils veulent peut-être
tiré leur épingle du jeu en tout cas je
pense ça c'est un choc intéressant de
joueurs qui montrent un tous les deux et
je pense simplement être intéressant
donc parti aspire aussi
dirrig grande elle use bong irrigue le
perdre il était depuis bien parti dans
ce format ouais ça c'est aussi une avait
eu la réussite comme tu dis ou en suisse
menait
mais dans une interview il a quand même
dit que
68 est en tête avec carcelle il disait
que c'était un peu comme au bon vieux
temps à l'époque où bref et je pense
qu'il a game maker baissé de bien finir
tous 1 3 qui joue chez lui à domicile et
la sueur bien sûr il ya une carte du
combat que la bonne foi reste ici a
éclaté
c'est l'us joué d'unir voir mais ça
s'est fini trop tôt pour josiane juste
fêter le seul mais j'aurais pas bête du
tout dès le début de la partie au fossé
l'ouverture jeudi qu'il allait décoller
veut dire je n'étais pas trois rêves
parce que c'était
mais je le voulais vraiment là bas voilà
donc du coup je pense que j'irai dans
news ça va jouer en tout cas avec cette
gagner et 12 avant de forest alors là ça
va dépendre pas savoir d'où d'ailleurs
un fait nul traitement contre son camp
et c'est parce qu'il avait tout perdu
leur rapidement parce que généralement
cesser un jour qu'il faille
pour le nez dans le bon sens du terme je
suis complètement d'accord avec toi je
cite souvent en exemple à mes élèves les
joueurs polonais pour leur combativité
je t'avais dit j'ai déjà fait un tournoi
en pologne avec avec des amis français
on avait tous lâché des points elo à
gogo et on était impressionné par la
combativité même des joueurs amateurs
modeste c'est vraiment eu une école un
peu à la durée du coup c
justement les traits de l'audace sont
intéressants par rapport à simple s'il a
gardé cette philosophie là alors qu il
est il a beaucoup plus de points elo qui
est beaucoup plus âgées etc ben voilà
c'est une mentalité et une mentalité de
de combat et c'est super quoi c'est
super c'était intéressant c'est des
bonnes valeurs en tout cas
ok on se fait un petit un petit tour des
héritiers du coup
il m'a vu il va y avoir 5 24 euros solim
au bon
passe pas grand chose de la pression
pour l'instant on sait assez basique
[Musique]
jusque là c'est une partie quoi joue
presque à thème pour les
cette fois donc après une répulsion
véritable là là moi je pense qu'il va se
passer c'est prend des gars et prend des
cartes c'est
peut-être fou processus généralement on
prend cette saisie et après on joue
comme elle et b en d2 pour échanger
lecavalier
donc je pense qu'on va avoir droit alors
pourquoi vous processus donc vous savez
que généralement garde les coûts dans
cette position le coup de carte blanche
sénat il a pas trop de monde à venir
parce que vous voyez monsieur mambé et 3
1 jour 20 par rapport à la structure h7
gccf celle que le foulard pas trop
d'avenir est donc généralement beaucoup
joué avec
on va manger en sel 6 échanger
lecavalier en d2 et donc on va jouer
avec cavaliers f3 fou c'est un contre
fout c'est 8 es fou g7 et on va j'en
veux être contre les fous parce que la
position à un peu compliqué le fou de 7
par exemple il pas bien joué donc place
à iliad il ya des ruptures etc et ceci
pour essayer d'ouvrir un petit peu le
fou mais la part de fous ici elle est
pas si bonne que ça pour les noirs donc
on va peut-être jouer à fond sur le
centre blanc donc comprendre et si c'est
normal ici donc des six cavaliers 2
c'est logique elle fut très juste
enlever les ça ne dérange pas enlever
les variantes
excuse moi sur le japon n'est pas encore
entré dans le vif du sujet voit ça on a
dit enfin c'est un nul sans module c'est
petite analyse comme ça ouais c'est
mieux je pense que vous travaillez aussi
un peu mine de rien ah oui et oui sophy
veut il veut bosser
je passe d'erreurs par an donc
[Rires]
et c'est logique c'est logique logique
logique ok on fait un petit tour des
échiquiers tranquille allez c'est parti
qu'est ce que tu veux aller voir en
premier quoi la partie demande fort est
ok bon ben on va les voir l'ouverture de
forêt sûr que tu insistes stouff
decaux a très bien une semi une semi
avec mon premier 600 normalement il n'ya
pas grand chose on va la regarder si
duda jouer ça en août qui veulent jouer
pour quelque chose nombre des cas des
cinq c4 on est dans le grand bi dame pas
souci c'est 6 annonce une slave donc
cela caractériser un parent par
secousses et 6 on tient le centre avec
un pion cavaliers f3 cavaliers f6 ks et
3 position normale la vraie slave ses
dépenses et
4.4 bref ça alors par exemple ça serait
logique seconds
[Musique]
n'ont ni été hier je n'étais même pas
sûr pièces comme pas sûr de chose comme
oui
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai on
est déjà parti et la veille au grain
nous on avait envie de vous mettre un
peu les scores pour important c'est
important de prendre conscience
que la journée et du seul perdu c'est ça
qui est un petit peu un petit peu
pénible du coup dans cette dans cette
situation voilà une thèse sur la
discussion slam se laver et se mit slave
puisqu'en fait il n'y a pas une et prend
ses quatre coups caractéristiques de la
slave il y a eu que six et
sur cela
on est dans une dans une comment
dirais-je smith l'art on a fait aussi ce
qui est d'un coup caractéristiques du
gambit dame refusé et c6 en même temps
voilà position de base de la position
vois certains schémas ensuite on a bien
tenu le sandre on fera des choix d'être
dépensé 4 avec du billet 5 ça c'est du
classique hélas les blancs le choix de
faire directement ou trois pour défendre
leurs pions c4 ou de faire la sortie du
fou angers 5 on met jamais en f4 c'est
une faute théorique déjà de le mettre en
oeuvre quatre à cause de dépenser 4
voilà et après a calé cinq voilà et du
coup le fond f cattier n'est pas bien
placé jusque là les noirs s'apprête à
manger en c4 et de tenir avec des cinq
dons ou g5 y ait joué là les dépenses et
4 m pour l'instant plus ou moins contré
par les quatre validé e5 même si il y en
a qui jouent avec ce genre d'idées mais
c'est plus c'est plus rare donc à chis
hélas le coût théorique on attend avant
de moscou seppois h 4 le plus théorique
le problème si ça existe ça a été joué
dans la partie c'est x h quatre bandes
marrante un stouff
séparant de
2,6 ici c'est exactement à vendre de
moscou chère mené une partie assez
récente et che par enough topalov qui
avait eu
au dernier top 12 en top 16 est
maintenant
du coup l'idée en fait c'est de pouvoir
rétorqué sur des princes et 4 on va
pouvoir sur le cadre perdre des gros g5
s'affaire une position assez complexes
ou g3 et b5 chien mon pion est en fait
les les noirs dans cette position ils
ont gagné un pion mais ils ont lâché le
sens de la position est hyper fun qui
franchement c'est ce qu'on aurait aimé
voir mais duda n'était pas d'accord il a
loué
ouais la variante considéré comme plus
égalisant mais bon les blancs toujours
en avantage aux échecs dans le début a
commencé les coups normaux donc la donne
et sa perte de fou contre une avance de
développement puisque on remarque qu'il
a sorti deux cavaliers et les noirs
n'ont pas c'est aussi une pièce à part
la dame ce qui est plutôt défaillant
normalement
le plan noir moment c'est de juger si ce
fou g7 après le plan le plus recommandé
même s'il est vrai que fout des six
existe aussi c'est à dire qu'il va
falloir montrer à tout le monde avec les
noirs que l'on a le plus de quinze lois
reglèment blanc ne l'ont pas voilà
l'idée de la position avec baignoire
dans dilemme blanc doit être hyper actif
pour profiter de leur avance de
développement mais c'est là que le coup
est un petit peu étonnante puisque assez
g3 qui a été choisi par par les blancs
est
ok c'est peut-être ça dans mes fiches
mais je suis incapable de vous dire ce
que j'ai sur ce coup j'ai droit qui est
pour moi pas trop dans l'esprit de la
position dans le sens où on à la paire
de fou contre nous sur le long terme
donc il faut être vraiment à ces actifs
un chat s'est étonnée du coup du coup
j'ai trois
oui c'est souvent comme ça qu'on joue se
trouve avec le 4 et les blancs et les
noirs des fois ne touche ne touche à
rien donc le cadre c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment dans l'esprit
de ce genre de position la fois faire
attention
peut-être qu'il y a des oeufs est fou b4
directement faudrait il faudra regarder
mais normalement ça va être un des indes
écroué ce que tu fais pas 3 d'abord plus
des 3 4 j'avoue que je sais plus trop
mais pour éviter d'en fait de prendre un
full méca t cha qui peut être un petit
peu un petit peu énervant oui parce que
là je pense trouve que si tu joues un
cadre directement j'ai peut-être des
oeufs perval yeux ou beckham pourra
faire parler mon fou de 15 mois voulu
montrer à tout le monde sur cavalier est
mené deux pions des quatre qui en l'air
donc on n'a pas envie de jouer ça tu vas
jouer qu'à et c3 est là si on est
logique avec l'état d'esprit de la
position noir pour vous montrer ce que
c'est le jeu de couleurs aux échecs j'ai
envie je sais pas si c'est vrai mais de
jouer ces cinq dans ce genre de position
pour essayer de faire parler le coup de
15 heures avec des cavaliers c6 vous
voyez la volonté en tout cas noir doit
doit être celle là d'après pour vérifier
mais ça allait recourir encore une
proposition
donc du coup on fait dans cette position
normalement de mémoire de trois ou d3
peu de cirage et on joue pour eux quatre
pendant ce temps là cavalier 17 ou des
trois là je peux même vous fondez si ça
existe mais c'est plutôt le g6
normalement petit rock food les 7 et la
carte est là avec baignoire je peux
choisir
nommant la marquise et pas forcément au
coût le plus le plus recommandé dans ses
positions dans ses positions là on n'est
pas nécessairement obligé parce que je
veux des fois je vois des positions il
ya 2,5 alors qu'est-ce qu'on joue si on
prend pas ce qu'est ce que je peux pas
dans votre moi je la paye tout connais
un peu de temps mais jamais tout cas
est-ce que je peux pas jouer un coup
comme dépensé 4 subi deux sacs 6,6 et
c'est normal dans la plupart des
positions
ici
si je suis pas sur
cinq poissons il y aurait des cinq et
ces structures là ce qui est assez
intéressant section décès ont fait
baisser pour contrôler les quinze
d'importantes blanche parce que sync
vous voulez jouer sur 15 mois au moins
qu'on n'a pas trop réussi notre mission
puisque le fou but sur du dur les blancs
eux sont en supériorité numérique de
pièces mineurs sur les cases blanches
ils sont trois pièces mineurs nous on a
que deux qui peuvent aller sur les cases
blanches du coup on essaie d'exploser
les cases blanches pour qu'on puisse
faire par
faire parler la supériorité voilà un
petit peu pour les idées et du coup j'ai
trois tu trouves tu vois c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un petit peu plus
étonnant c'est pas très tranchant mais
pourquoi pas tous jouent qu'à et 17
rouge et ne c'est normal mais du coup
voilà c'est un petit peu la question qui
est posée par par band forrest hippiques
l'option c4 parce que le fou est parti
or de se contrôler la foule est placé 4
mais du coup c'est quand même plutôt
plutôt sympa
c'est franchement intéressant
franchement intéressant du coup d'oeil
s'en fichent petit rock et là on est
dans les positions de base type
variantes de moscou
puisque j'ai un peu plus nette j'ai même
la perte de fou
mais les blancs des compensations ça
fait penser aux pressions de catalan si
tu veux un chirac en scène où les blancs
ont infligé deux et est finalement une
initiative prochaine mais un peu moins
non là il faut se connaître enfin il
faut savoir comment je vais disposer mes
pièces maintenant
c'est pas si évident déjà après par
rapport à une variante de moscou j'ai
pas dû me compromettre avec un coup
comme g5 pour gagner le pion
par contre ceux qui veulent faire des
cinq pour bien tenir le pion faudra
faire attention à cette diagonale un que
magnus carlsen exploite être très bien
fait là il faut déterminer pour moi
l'urgence de la position si je regarde
ici c'est
mais
bien souvent voyager si ce projet c'est
parce que là c'est pertinent ça avoir vu
la disposition mise en place par
par les blancs je peux aussi jouer food
et si ces dames 7
j'ai plusieurs choix et les vents de
forest il doit déjà réfléchir à la
position tranquillement bon c'est pas
mal déjà ce qu'on a fait tous font pour
aller voir ou vraiment c'est la partie
que tu as envie d'aller voir maintenant
ps
choisit alors y avait parti que je
trouvais assez marrante et a participé
au rapport et
c'est important parce que rapporte il
est très très bien classés 1
apple serré c'est le seul qui pourrait
éventuellement entraver 45 ouais je vous
rappelle qu'à recel il a un groupe en
avance sur le rapport mais demain il a
gagné ouais ça c'est dommage ça ça et me
la mets un franchement il ya que le
convive qui nous permet de voir ça mais
si si il fait 2 sur 2 il peut rattraper
quoi sauf si karzaï gagné janvier du
coup rapport non plus une partie avoir
fumé cinq cavaliers f6 donc volonté
normalement d'aller vers
vers une berlinoise en fait avec
[Musique]
petit rock quel point les 400 voyait
souvent qu'à valider 6 où pranger 6e
français si c'est vraiment de haut
niveau qu'on appelle le mur de berlin en
fait pourquoi parce qu'on arrive très
vite avec un échange et dames pour des
rockets avec une meilleure structure
puisque les noirs ils ont je faire
montrer cela peut-être un petit peu vite
quand même on voit une structure blanche
elle est meilleure que celle des noirs
mais ils ont à perdre de fou voilà tout
l'enjeu de cette position jouer au
niveau très très régulièrement par tous
les meilleurs joueurs
car c'est en fait tous les hors du top
10 je joue ça n'est pas pour bloquer
avec baignoire le joueur blanc donc je
rappelle comme on l'obtient cavaliers
fils sa annonce la petit range cavaliers
prend 1,4 on mène on accepte de prendre
l'option centrale on a un roi qui est
pas encore safe
et sur des quatre ont fait cavaliers des
six pour enlever peut-être perd 2,4 à
être tranquille on attend que le fourbe
et 5 il ya plusieurs
sas et karakar qu'exactement et du coup
là il ya des coups rigolons un même si
les meilleurs joueurs mondiaux du top
mondial il faut comprendre ces scissions
prince et six les joueurs funky des fois
ils font des points 5 par exemple ça
existe aussi et si sûr car les 1er 5 à 4
eh bien regardez
le cavalier est enfermé voilà bon bref
on pourrait rigoler avec pas mal de
ligne autour de sa place est très
théorique et la d3 c'est une variante
plus piano plus tranquille on va
jusqu'au d'échec on a les blancs et là
je ne connais pas tout ce qui a été joué
dans la ligue cette stat 1 un défaut
mais qui a valu à s'être n'aurait eu je
les ai vus dans une partie
sur internet alors si c'est plus te dire
que si c'était nakamura ou la scène
c'était 1-1 un tournoi sur internet avec
des forts joueurs et j'ai vu ce cavalier
ou 7 ça me dit quelque chose enfin un
port où un
rapport qu'il avait déjà joué je crois
que ces rapports
arsène d'ailleurs on peut compter deux
jours j'ai gagné ici
mais vous devez vous demander pourquoi
il s option 1,5 mais ça c'est assez
connus qu'on a cavalé 1,5 il ya toujours
les chèques de la dame qui inquiète m
connue alors moi qui ne connaissait pas
la position je me pose la question jean
cavalier prend 1,5 à ce qui se passe je
vous pouvez 5 et cavaliers 5 attaquer
j'imagine que c'est si ce doit être pas
mal
avec l'histoire de la dame à saint qui a
deux rouges ici vous voyez kevin est ce
que je suis un génie ou pas je vois de
cette base car c'est très fort mais tu
vois là tu nous régale c'est tout vu
nous régale en théorie maintenant on
aura tout vu
mais oui il me semble et vous avez vu ça
et ça s'est joué au norwich s ouais en
fait plus m c'est pas sur internet par
contre j'ai une faute ça s'est joué au
nord-ouest yes en 2021 c'est un coup
manger on en souffre ouais ouais alors
quand tu la gamme qui le joue
c'est marginal des super comme quoi la
mer rapport dit au mac do sul au mcdo
tlumak d'oslo
leurs griefs par avion
alors tous que c'est bien la pac
mac d'oslo c'est pas une jeune fille
norvégienne a annoncé
[Musique]
que macbeth la sécession de la
prononciation
moi je l'appelle dans ma tête mac do sul
où tu vois une prune production bretonne
quoi tu vois des trucs ce que magna
d'oslo ah ouais c'est pas mal aussi mais
je ne sais pas comment dire je sais pas
comment on dit
d'ailleurs
cessé
jn rives qui est bon pour pour les noms
comme ça on se moquait beaucoup de lui
en équipe de france à ce sujet parce
qu'il nous inventer des joueurs à chaque
fois tu sais que moi j'ai beaucoup de
mal avec ainsi penco je dis souvent et
peace and co mais lui il vous est pas
mal de
deux choses comme cela s est s est
vraiment bon c'est vraiment blond e la
surca et c4 si le chat et réveillez vous
me prenez en baissant coupin voilà mac
d'oslo c'est aussi ce qui nous a mis
amadeus
salut il y pas salut a tous un qui sont
arrivés petit à petit j'ai bien aimé le
mcs d'oslo
il ya plusieurs idées par rapport à ça
donc à eséka récemment je m'en fous b5
ou pas souvent
parce que vous savez on fera un match et
souffre donc j'essaye de le tester un
petit peu pour voir s'il était en forme
et oui bah this way non mais je l'aimais
bon ça marche pas à oued dessin qu'on se
retrouve avec avec tout en l'air je
contrôle la case des six en plus on peut
on peut s'amuser avec avec pas mal de
coups dans cette position ce qui est
assez marrant comme tel jouer cavalier
g6 dans cette position ça serait pas
impossible avec pas d'casqué parce que
surtout un cadre mais toujours b5 pour
faire fourchette fois l'horreur quoi
l'horreur absolue on a compris on va
jamais prendre option là on va jamais
prendre ce point là donc cavalier seul
ok on n'y va pas cavaler c3 ça peut bien
sûr laisser celle ci c'est un futur des
5 1/2 d'avoir joué comme cela donc il ya
eu celle ci d'ailleurs après c'est
logique tous ses cadres par contre j'ai
le problème ne sera qu on sait que
c'était plutôt qu'un voyage et 6 l'idée
il a joué avec des six donc on va voir
après un petit peu la disposition des
pièces petit rock
ashes d'accord donc en jeu devenant des
noirs souvent le coup ashes voilà dans
les positions bizarres sur des cartes il
a joué dames c'est ça dépend de 15,5 et
il ya pas mal de temps maintenant on
dirait plutôt une italienne et le le
coup moderne qui l'avait cavaliers h4 et
regardez là l'idée de rapporte c'est
déjà un gros
g5y camaguey centre stable ouais mais là
du coup la suite à des marbres
je me demande si c'est bien que
je pense parce qu'il a regardé la
journée prend un des princes il a joué
rapidement d'un f3 pour menacer le
cavalier m6 et pour lost et son cavalier
en f5
voilà et
s'ils changent pas les cas marne on
risque de me le dire c'est bien sous ta
pas répondu personne personne m'a fait
la remarque
voilà et merci à rhein
qui cite du bof
bof c'est pas
et salut à toi lilio je n'avais pas vu
dans notre chat il ya du monde c'est
cool on va se passer une bonne après mme
avec des partis qui vont être funky kf5
c'est sympa ou prend pions prendre non
vous le savez on connaît par coeur le
jeu de couleurs les noirs doivent jouer
sur noirs et les blancs doivent jouer
sur blanc basique
tour des huîtres ou des 3 ok la position
elle est assez
assez folle déjà un tel déséquilibre et
j'ai une préférence pour les blancs
parce que là on a trop la valorisation
du coup j'ai cet
appui à des gammes d affaiblissement
certaines cases et la paire de couche
gelée blanche
le pion au sein qui peut être des fois
tu m'aimes petit rock bon faut voir si
c'est comme souffler pas trop mettre mon
roi avec baignoire le roi blanc est
vraiment bien sécurisé
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on puisse
balancer y perd facilement l'élection
comme ça parce que je manque de soutien
ok alors peut-être passé je trouve
quelque chose comme ça voilà mon roi il
ya toujours la question du roi qui n'est
pas réglé vous faites la cabanasse tout
votre monde pam pam voilà
le gros câlin manu est de retour pour
tous voilà et vous voulez parce que le
grand comme tout le monde il fait roi
des ses droits civiques et c'est pas
bête du tout hein
c'est pousser notre côté mais on peut se
demander pourquoi alors on l'a pas fait
dire à quoi puisqu'ils avaient
l'occasion mahdia le pian et cette
remarque ans hier donc déjà c'est une
petite explication
tour des huit parcs ou des 3 et
maintenant on a dix-sept pas assez vite
et ouais ouais ça serait cosmique à
cette fois garde il y avait alors
surtout ses claques se joue dans ce roi
17 je rêve ou c4 et jouffroy 8 et la
répétition
je pense que cela passe passe et clame
sa cavale y ait eu des cinq a été joué
donc ça semble logique
pour les caser cavaliers 1,4 aussi
maintenant on a l'impression que les
blancs sont juste mieux ok ça promet ça
promet cette partie on continue notre
petit
je peux défendre en mettant le cavaliere
4d fois ou alors en faisant cavalier f6
genre cavaliers h 50 jours et dam des
trois forêts dh 5 et le fouloir loi
dépend de
5,8
si tu mets un jour tu as mangé trois
marées ou son poids il peut y avoir des
cavaliers hashtag par exemple pour faire
coups de pied coups de poing tu mets un
petit coup de pied plutôt que de réagir
en défendant pur mamba j'essaie de
contre-attaqués ça c'est important à
comprendre et du cou du coup c'est pas
si dangereux le fait que le fou g7
dépendre indirectement
le pion aux cinq ça c'est cool c'est
cool et pas de problème
donc ok on est on est vraiment facile
par rapport à tout cela et du coup on va
on va avancer stouff vers les autres
partis
j'ai envie de te faire plaisir stouff
dis-moi dix mots tu vas aller
tu me parles hésitant t'as rien vu de
11 mois c'est moins drôle quoi ouais
ouais t'as pas tonton petit poulain mais
il a déjà gagné donc ça se compte en ont
peut aller voir peut-être notre petite
frenchie aux siens s'est vraiment animée
on va aller faire un petit tour pour
dire bonjour un autre petit frenchy ça
fait un moment que je n'ai pas vu mais
j'ai suivi quand même son tournoi et on
avait senti les prémices quand même un
d'un retour c'était sa partie contre
morzine où il avait très bien joué 1
on parle donc de marc landry maori dit
qu'il ya ici les pièces noires et
du coup par rapport par rapport à son
tournoi il était en grande difficulté
dans le début du tournoi et il s'est
vraiment repris de manière hyper
convaincante il vient d'enchaîner 1 2 me
sur 3 si je dis pas de bêtises souffre
avec deux victoires contre dan dah et
contrebande fort est le frère de jordan
et entre temps
il a fait une nulle et je ne sais plus
contre qui
mais tu vas me le dire tout parce que tu
es très bon
à vos questions
je me suis rappelé des deux victoires 2
marc andry mais j'ai oublié compte
qu'ils avaient fait nul entre temps
van damme mais je crois je crois que
c'est ça j'ai fait il dit
et l'autre
[Musique]
il est il est complètement revenue dans
le tournoi et de façon sa qualité de jeu
avait été étaient présents donc y'a pas
de soucis particuliers et il joue encore
son son psy gambie dames avec 1,6 voilà
même sur ces quatre voilà ils jouent ce
second remis damas six et on voit
souvent la façon conventionnelle de
contrer ce coût à 6 c'est de faire ces
bandes est comme ça il n'y a jamais pris
ces quatre baies 5 à regarder voilà déjà
c'est plus possible et le coup à six est
peut-être moins utile dans cette
position-là cavaliere trois cavaliers m6
on voit que marc landry avait bossé ce
système pour le tournoi foulée 5 x 6
jusque là tout va bien
c'est normal je dirais ou province 6
pourquoi pas même si on voit pas
l'intérêt tout de suite à part faire
bouger la dame et c'est ce que le joueur
vos gueules a voulu exploiter la ensuite
joué d'un bep droit il provoque un coup
bizarre en l'occurrence tour à 7 est le
moins mauvais sans doute ici puisque je
touche pas à mes pions donc la publie
pas le pion csn je pourrai toujours
maintenance et 6 quand il faudra donc
voilà l'explication de tours 7 c'est pas
un coup qu'on fait avec grand plaisir
mais si ma penderie laver dans sa
préparation
c'est
c'est tout simplement parce qu'il a
gagné la paire de fou donc il fait une
petite concession pour le moment mais il
ya eu concession de l'adversaire sur un
autre registre donc ça se tient ça se
tient ouais mais on le voit souvent tour
à 7 dans les dents les pollutions bien
sûr
c'est quoi ces thématiques parce qu'on
veut pas où on va pas toucher des pions
en fait exactement parce qu'on veut
faire des pions la tour n'est pas
attaquable oui je suis maman on a déjà
joué ce gland en partie en partie lente
donc c'est vraiment un thème classique
dans l'esclave particulièrement et du
coup il ya eu à 3
hélas ce qui est assez étonnant c'est
qu'on n'avait pas fait mais cinq au
coude avant et maintenant il l'a fait
stouff moi je vais te laisser nous
expliquer ça pendant que je branche mon
cas ce que ça c'est assez intéressant
j'ai 1 200
alors ce qu'on peut imaginer en fait
c'est que s'il avait cinq pirates à 401
coup l'année dont je vois trois ont
perdu un temps en tête maintenant que je
vais tout restait qu'à toi mieux placés
en ascète quant à 8 et du coupé s5 est
peut-être plus besoin est par exemple un
après b5
bastille maintenant on joue à quatre la
junte en avance donc est ce que
maintenant je peux jouer à peut-être b4
ou est ce que pouvait mieux des coups
comme
dans ce bon mais en fait peut-être
qu'après je peux gagner du temps avec vu
ses 50 ans qui peut bouleverser manger
par conte à 8 heures le repas mais tout
simplement
jouer à 4 la saa
patrick roy
j'ai rien qu'en fait tout dans celle là
c'est toujours la 4g bientôt
on est bien content que tu vois que tu
es tout est simple direct et rue à 4 je
veux tour à 7 à 3 des 5 à 4 donc c'est
la même position qu'avant mais avec
trois sets du coup jouer à 4 et 6 c
aurait pas trop trop de sens dans l'idée
que la fin ça ça ça confirmerait bien
que trois sets étaient telles coupes on
voit
du coup tu sais pas ce qu'il faut jouer
ou pas à 4
donc il ya maintenant le pion à cinq ans
mais
on est cinq voiliers
moi sans doute
bien placé là la dame est ce qu'on peut
mettre ça accélère chaude le prend dans
ce championnat voyez il ya le poids
vis-à-vis flou dame donc maintenant il
reste plus qu'à gagner la pièce et
trouver le meilleur coup
madame f5 d'amd 8 cosson qu'on dit son
candidat
j'aime bien même des huit invalider ces
six
sur 4 gc ci soit voilà
ce qu'on est venu je pensais adam f 100
m haies qui avait cinq tout pas si clair
bon ça se voyait sur la nappe moi je
pensais aux quatre ans prince fumée
cavalia trois
jeunes
habitués des petites pointes tactique
mais là c'est le début du tri michaud
pichot
et ce sera pire demain matin sous peu
après 8 heures du matin
samedi soir modeste à buenos aires est
ce soir
alors ce soir je vais au théâtre
owen tu t'en bourgeoise est ou pas oui
ce séjour argentin a fait énormément de
bien là voudraient bien de théâtre plus
en plus en plus ok là il faut il faut
tester un peu tard vint pas
ça peut être moins sympa
pourquoi pas mais bon
je dois confesser que je ne sais pas
beaucoup au théâtre
puis
j'ai pas beaucoup au théâtre
[Musique]
on après midi avec le tannat style donc
j'ai pas ça serait remontant de voir du
spectacle tout le temps de voir des
spectacles tout le temps sauf non mais
c'est sympa c'est un autre registre non
je ne vais pas au terme de la misère
pourtant il y en a un là mézières un
petit théâtre un petit théâtre tout
voilà donc dans ma belle bretagne et
mais du coup il y avait cinq dames c'est
2 après cette petite digression fois f5
un tag la dame on replace le fou d'amd
de ses six maps klaus mais en train de
réorganiser toutes ces pièces est là
maintenant vous voyez ce que tout nous
indiquer
tout à l'heure la tour elle est vivante
sur la rangée elle va bientôt venir sur
l'échiquier on va déjà sortir le fouet
est fluide donc j'ai trois fous des 6 1
et maintenant on voit on va bien sortir
bien sortir les pièces faut les deux
petits rock
et mme chirac a été joué
bon il a eu ce qu'il voulait comme
position je pense un prêt en termes de
plan
la tendance et 4 c'était une mauvaise
idée il y avait les 17 b 6 6 4 voilà le
plan de souffre
et en contrepartie j'aimerais bien jouer
pour eux car avec les règles et blanc
pour valoriser les cases blanches et à
fabien c'est aussi mais j'ai pas ce
schéma là qui est connue je n'ai pas
comment je vais faire le cavalier h4
alors je fais ça ça pour aller aussi sur
les cases c'est un peu long terme alliés
hkm de ce tout pour faire quatre
fois par an que je traîne ou pas laisser
les noirs stabiliser ok partie
équilibrée en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
peut dire pour pour marquer car
relativement bien réussi son ouverture
avec les noirs il a une position
équilibrée c'est ce qu'on demande il
faut pas prendre l'eau dans l'ouverture
c'est le risque avec avec les noirs et
là c'est pas du tout le cas donc une
position prometteuse ça va être assez
intéressant
et ce qui va continuer sa marche en
avant dans le classement appel et il
était il était longtemps longtemps
dernier maintenant il a un point
d'avancé sur le dernier
assurément il vise le milieu de tableau
et
il a un peu décroché un des tout
meilleurs et puis le groupe de tous
meilleurs c'est à partir de cinq et demi
je dirais et m on a par contre il faut
bien le site est à nouveau erré ghazi
qu'à neuf points stouff il a neuf points
sur 11 le monstre c'est le monstre mais
c'est à laval on s'avance three main
avant de commencer ton est tout à fait
l'avis attention
mais tu m'en avait parlé déjà en
championnat du monde de rapides si je
dis pas de bêtise de ce joueur qui était
très impressionnant
l'ensemble soit pas du monde de rapides
j'avais dit que ce jour 84 à lui très
dangereux et il a il a très bien marché
du monde de blitz ont l'habitude était
plus la main pendant très longtemps et
il a perdu les quatre dernières parties
a trop tard ultime numéro deux après une
dizaine de secondes et non même même
plus parce qu'ils verront donc à après
15 secondes il était de rendre deuxième
et et la fille par perdre entre 4 4 de
finale comme ça et là il est bon et j'ai
vu d'ailleurs même l'interview de 45
hier ou avant-hier
après je suis donc après avoir gagné
contre
compte qu'ils avaient gagné
pour qui l'amérique à celle là récemment
à
la meignanne bretagne ouais après après
avoir battu mamediarov et bains où on
n'en a pas fait nul je crois contre
conflans d'une carrière chine après
l'avocat la kiné m'a fait des interviews
et en fait
on la potée gassion savoir qu'est ce
qu'ils pensaient des airs et gazés et
est ce que bon se promener
et l'a dit non mais en fait quasi c'est
de loin le meilleur voire de challenger
et c'est pas ne s'est pas
pour lui c'est pas étonnant qu'ils
gagnent au challenger c'est normal mais
il dit que ce qui est impressionnant
c'est de voir combien de points il met
au deuxième point il marque en fait dans
le coma oui parce qu'il avec me 708
complètement m et donc il va faire deux
nuls d'affilée donc les lacs de la 911
qui est
moyenne et l'eau a
et e et là c'est pas du rapid quoi c'est
dû lancer pour moi le vrai jeu donc
c'est ya pas de variance moi c'est pas
c'est pas du hasard ont déjà les 26 30
mais pas une performance comme ça je
sais pas il va finir avec +30 peut-être
point l'eau quasiment quoi donc là il
est en train de s'en approcher il va
rentrer dans le top 100 mondial et après
il risque vite de rentrer dans le top 50
on va voir s'il n'est pas capable
d'aller chatouiller les gros joueurs est
d'arriver à plus de 2700 rapidement et
ça c'est super quand ça va bien ça le
disait avoir 2007 très bientôt ouais
c'est ça et il a dit qu'il avait un il
avait un oeil tactique enfin il voyait
très bien athlétique très très vite et
il est aussi capable de changer de style
facilement quand il le faut et en fait
il harangue c'est un très bon joueur
avec une 2007
il ya aussi élogieux à son sujet c'est
quand même qu'il ya cinq ans planant
et l'aviron va ça confirme tous cru
depuis le début pour moi ça fait des
mois et des mois que je suis ici ce soir
et que je dis que lui ça faisait 10 à 18
ans la loi n'a pas raison et ce qui est
marrant c'est que aujourd'hui
il joue un joueur il n'a pas encore
gagné le tournoi parce qu'elle choix
d'un des joueurs qui le talonne entre
guillemets avec mois et demi donc le
talonner c'est un grand mot mais ces
parties intéressantes on va on va aller
juste voir leurs positions
si tu veux stouff et
du coup on est dans une variante
vraiment classique c'est un gambit dame
refusait de base et il a joué à trois
pieds pas le coup le plus conventionnel
on connaît plutôt les coups comme e3 ici
stouff dans dans ce genre de position il
a joué à la crème des six ok il a décidé
de prendre des cinq bons il s'est pas
encore passé et des millions de choses
parti en cours et il ya le petit plus
des blancs voilà on va voir on va voir
tout à l'heure ce que donne ce que donne
cette partie ok bon parti bienvenue à
toi sur le stream fatou way salut à tous
ceux qui arrivent en cours
alors du coup on repart dans le a et
qu'est ce qu'on va aller voir comme
parti c'est toi qui choisis annoncé un
gros choc entre vite et visiter
mamediarov on va l'avoir on va aller on
va les voir tout ça
alors déjà on les a à l'écran et
maintenant que la position
une italienne de la vienne avec ses
trois voilages on va vous montrer
comment en arriver là donc quatre
cinquièmes c'est du grand classique et
l'italienne fous ces cinq classiques
aussi on peut le vrai cavalier f6 ça
dépend de chacun et maintenant c'est
trois avec la grosse menace des quatre
dont les joueurs je cavaliers f6 pour
taper le 4 et ainsi empêcher des
400 euros pêche se la jouer la théorie
n'indique pas ce coup là parce que là il
ya fou mais quatre échecs ce que nous
fouillent attaquer donc pas prendre ces
trois points c'est pas un gambit qui
vont en fait c'est là nul de haut niveau
on peut obtenir nul mais cavaliers
pointe vous voulez vous parler des
variantes de folie avec des cinq
peut-être trouve c'est ça tu voulais
aller dans cette danse est grosse baston
qui existe et là c'est vraiment des
complications tu fais oui c'est petit
aubin nom fu c3 et les cinq que je
voulais le montrer voilà et ça avantage
les noirs
wen s'est mis à des positions peu que
l'action contre le jeu quand on bat
quand on est jeune et sympathique sympa
mais sinon c'est pas un truc mais sinon
avant au niveau à la place de jouer deux
aux cavaliers c'est rohff de carélie des
deux fois pas an phu des 2 oui oui tout
à fait tout à fait et cavaliers pro
rider 5 voilà
donc on est sur des choses un peu plus
un peu plus modeste normalement dans
celle-là avec avec la foulée quatre fous
des deux fous prendrait deux cavaliers
pro d2 des cinq et on voit beaucoup nul
à haut niveau comme cela a prises
cavaliers prend d'un bep trois cavaliers
à 5
dans la catéchèse elle va lire via les
joueurs de haut niveau des fois ce qu'on
vous dit des fois dans certains tournois
voilà pas le droit de faire nul
ok c'est bien c'est franchement le
fameux droit de faire nul arrange et si
vous voulez le problème c'est que c'est
pas du tout
gérable
les joueurs qui veulent s'arranger à
l'avance pourront toujours le faire
jusque là c'est une répétition si vous
voulez qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire contre
ça et les répétitions dans ce type de
tournois sont autorisés à il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas le choix et du coup les
arbitres soient obligés de constater que
la marcal à trois fois la même position
hockey châtaignes le cavalier le
meilleur coup ici c'est un cavalier à 5
c c'est tranquille donc finalement cette
règle d'interdiction nul est très bien
pour les jeunes pour inculquer des
valeurs mais les joueurs pros qui
veulent la contourner la composeront
toujours et sans aucun problème
si on
dans des rapides par exemple on donne un
nombre de points supplémentaires pour
pour la victoire un peu comme en foot si
le trois points la victoire un point le
match nul mais c'est pas la solution
idéale non plus il ya des vrais nul de
combat
qui sont très belles et du cou
ça donnerait trop d'importance à la
victoire par rapport à ces nuls de
combat donc c'est extrêmement compliqué
et on avait une question d'amadeus
soudain la chatte kg 10 mars les gars
pourquoi je plus l'écossaise ce que moi
je vous sachez que 1004 mais je trouve
que c'est une très bonne ouverture mais
je la classerais troisième un ton
ouverture amadeus derrière l'espagnol l
italienne c'est vrai qu'elle est en fait
très correct mais ils ont des niveaux
tels de préparation théorique que les
blancs ne trouve pas davantage dans
l'écossaise on va dire au niveau parce
que les noirs au fil du temps et de
l'évolution des modules ont réussi à
trouver des ressources c'est clairement
pour ça qu'elle est moins joué voilà
enfin sauf si souvent envie de rajouter
quelque chose mais mais c'est de toute
façon c'est forcément ça explique
assiette en fait à haut niveau ça se
joue plus parce que voilà comme je viens
de le dire la théorie fait qu' il trouve
pas de moyens d'améliorer d'avoir
davantage mais ensuite au niveau
amateurs ou débutants enfin tout ça les
quoi ça sert là c'est très très bonne
ouverture moi je la joue par exemple
faire plaisir aussi un donkament année
où tu peux continuer à jouer pendant des
lustres un an toute ta vie dans des
positions qui sont assez ouverte et qui
permettent d'avoir le centre d'avoir les
pétales qui met pour attaquer ou alors
que ce soit italiennes espagnoles tu as
un peu plus de mal généralement plus
vers cette position ouverte
donc du coup c'est une bonne ouverture 1
mais juste à haut niveau ça se voit pas
ce que eux ils ont des rêves
c'est là
et ça rime est beaucoup plus dans les
années 90 2000 jusqu'à 2010 de voir
régulièrement des écossaises
et ça c'est un petit peu perdu et je
parle de ça parce qu'il ya une question
de tortue magique sur le même sujet en
fait c'est pourquoi je devrais pas le
gambit evans quoi avec béatrice i qui
vise d'attirer soit le cavalier ou fou
sur la case bécade pour faire ces trois
des cadres et la même réponse que l'on
peut faire dans les années 90 les
modules de recherche qui aide les
joueurs à se préparer n'était pas aussi
fort et maintenant on évite de faire des
ouvertures marginal sinon contre des
joueurs de très haut niveau hyper bien
préparé généralement ça ne passe pas y'a
encore quelques joueurs quand tu as
comme richard rapporte comme je bave à
qui cc à des variantes voie la plus
rigolote mais généralement ça marche pas
très bien même rapporte on voit que pour
arriver au niveau qu'il a aujourd'hui
c'est à dire entre de 1750 et 2800 il
s'est beaucoup calmé dans son style on
voit que la rapporte c'est un joueur
normal du top niveau et je obama qui est
l'autre joueur très fantasque y avait
des masses et les 2700 mais en fait il
est en dessous de 2006 sont aujourd'hui
il gagne régulièrement des blitz
toujours c'est un super joueur mais
c'est pas facile de se maintenir avec ce
style un peu borderline au niveau des
ouvertures les joueurs l'ont bien
compris et on a de plus en plus le style
de carlson qui apparaît c'est à dire le
jeu agréé blanc pour une position à deux
résultats vraiment on ne peut pas perdre
et on peut pousser un mini plus est
embêté l'adversaire même si on a assisté
aussi à des variantes plus folles dans
début que ce jeu pour petit plus mais
majoritairement on voit ce genre de
joueur mais c'est pour ça qu'on aime
bien par exemple mvl parce que lui joue
plus sur le fil du rasoir il est encore
à ses
fantasmes c'est pas le mot mais il joue
risquait il vous des lignes tranchante
parce qu'il a des facultés calculatoire
hyper importante voilà sur le sujet et
on va peut-être revenir un peu à la
partie entre vie dit emma m parce qu'on
n'a pas encore vu le souffre
alors du coup des trois des six
petit rock
c'est la façon tranquille de jouer
l'italienne l'italienne c3 detroit on
voit très souvent le plan de base et en
jouant pour d4
voilà donc un cheese tour un
petit rocha et mes deux
foulées 6 h 3 qui évite ouvriers cadres
cavalier e set et on est parti pour des
quatre quarts des plans clé évidemment
dans cette position dans ces moments là
vous allez voir oui pardon tout mais
seulement voilà le juste c'est marrant
fait de ce qui s'est passé parce que
quand on voit des quatre
jeux par les blancs et les noirs ont
refait cavale et sans rien
malheureusement les blocs ajouter 3 pour
répéter la position non j'essaie de
faire nul
structure c'est ce qu'on peut dire ce
qui explique le choix des noirs donc si
on s'entendait plus tôt qui a un coût
comme cavalier g6 pour valoriser
peut-être le chemin du cavalier
en fait je pense que ce qu'il veut c'est
essayer de provoquer une réaction au
centre donc soit avec des cinq pour
fermer la position et dans ce cas il va
revenir avec cavaliers en 7 g 6 soit
provoqué un échange au centre mais là
y'a eu à quatre
cavaliers à forts appuis adjoint aussi
sur le coup
conventionnel que j'attends depuis
longtemps parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
voit souvent cavalier développer mais
bon c'est pas c'est pas forcément plus
d'un cartilage ce qui s'est passé
et
apparaissent assez logique sous de faire
aussi à terme flou b3 mon peu plus en
fait qui a laissé six qui est malin
c'est que ça fait pression sur sur
l'option des
4es du coup il ya une menace parce que
si je fais kamali f1 je peux faire ça ça
et des cinq ont changé cavaliers pour
1,4 même cavalier pour un cadre souple
c'est rigolo
oui
voyez hein parce que
si on
avait compté une partie un peu pareil
l'ex amie et on l'avait dit renaud mais
que fout et 3 c'était pour anticiper que
sur des cinq des noirs on voudrait
vraiment joué 5 avec les blancs et pussy
le four est censé 4 et mayer plein de
trucs avec des cinq diact va forcer une
prise en deux cinq ou alors qu'elle
valait prendre 4 avec il ya des 5 qui
arrive aussi fort chaque donc du coup
on peut se demander si le coût de
bekaert ce n'était pas un peu précipité
à cause justement ce cas et c6 qui tape
le pion en fait il ya une idée gâchée
l'idée qu'à chaîne apparaît là en visite
il a joué la carte qui est assez
intelligent
parce qu'à des idées 2 à 5 on pouvait se
demander
comment
moment il allait faire clairement en cas
d'arrêt en cas de 6 ans des quatre il y
avait un bel hymne
pour que je prends direct way rally ce
que j'ai à 5,2 lorsque j'ai cavaler
prendre prise cavell
f3000 doyen mais on craignait peut-être
forcément mais
je dors à simple pas si facile donc à 5
j'avais vu j'ai toujours cavaliers pros
m3 intermezzo je peux le faire avant
après ça ça
et ça aussi c'est pas un truc avec un
b4g gc j'ai pas trouvé souffre l'instant
je suis je fis démunis pour vous dire ce
qui était prévu par jour les deux y
aurait à 6 oui c'est ça je me cachais 1
c'est un grand classique
comme ça aille m'en fous
et j'arrive pas à trouver comment
profiter du fou en c5 stouff il pour
l'instant coincé
on sent qu'il ya du potentiel
non mais il ya peut-être rien de clair
c'est juste une avance de développement
et
peut-être
on a envie de faire quelque chose on
essaie de trouver la ressource dynamique
avec souffle donc sur food et deux pour
vous et par tous est logique de faire à
6 il ya pas le choix en fait ce qu'il y
avait quatre qui menace
mais c'est pas si facile mais en fait
il avait dit prévoir quelque chose quand
même choqué prendre des cartes est ce
qu'on a raté a raté le coche
à peut-être que tu as peut-être que ta
cavale et prend des 4 comprend et
cavaliers de b3 qui
peut-être un jour comme eux 5 on attire
le fou en d4 comprends vos et marceau et
maintenant cavalier b3 et contrôler les
deux cases là où 1,5 vous voyez tout ce
que c'est pas jouable à cause de f4 qui
en ferme le goût surtout b6 de toute
façon il y aura à 5
la botte secrète et moi pas si secrète
que ça c'est la mode la mode voyante
plus tôt et
j'ai souvent une part secrète
la voix de secret passer
[Rires]
un bon petit jeu argentin sur la chemise
pour fêter la botte secrète
désolé désolé c'est de ma faute en plus
je suis pas à moitié désolé parce que
c'est le seul un seul sur le dos du
covin et ça c'est quand même moche ou c5
et la
compo simone cros quel point dans cette
position parce qu'à une perte de goût et
la structure ne serait plus aussi bonne
pour l'adversaire donc il ya plusieurs
plusieurs écoles mais cavaliers profond
et très plaisant et on peut peut-être
faire les 2 e 5 et cavaliers prend fou
dans la foulée j'aime beaucoup la
position non mais on a au moins cavalier
prend fou n'oubliez pas voulu de cela on
comprend maintenant ce qui est vu glisse
mais oublié quelque chose que prisse
décale s'éprend d'éclat et maintenant
regardez bien la structure magnifique
pour les blancs et ben c'était prévu par
m'améliorer cette structure magnifique
qu'il allait pas la laisser il vient lui
offrir ça mais seulement pour un demi
coup puisque derrière il a balancé des
sacs
qui est une réaction archi classique
dans ce genre de position il des cinq
forcément cavaliers prend des singles
et là est ce qu'on peut et est-ce qu'on
peut jouer avec ses pions isolé plein
milieu est-ce qu'on a des compensations
en échange
on va bien comme cavalier ya
donc sauf il veut profiter de la vence
de développement ils ont aimé la pièce
comme les blancs
je vérifiais qui avait pas de petites de
petites astuces
j'ai peut-être une petite astuce mais ça
à voir se retourner contre moi cette
histoire je suis en train de regarder
les cavaliers 5 c'est pas sûr je les
écarte en mer
pour beaucoup en fait il se gare et le
taps
jeu peut menacer un coup comme fou de
deux
parce en fait
si tu prends des quatre morts et menace
a 5 à 6 moi en d4 le cavalier basée à 5
annoncé qu'elle allait prendre un proche
pour s'attaquer au oui oui ça marche
quand même parce que quand tu manges
avec un f3 imaginons jouera
pas ce que je pourrais toujours faire
ainsi soit 5 mai la position et est
bonne bon je vous aussi ce
g7
non mais on peut être tout cas au cica
et c5 aussi regarde l'air oui
on oublie né à la fois de la tactique et
du piège mais aussi une amélioration
lente de position il fait un coup
multifonctions qui nourrit la tactique
et la stratégie en même temps donc ça
s'est passé par le cavalier au cap de
stuff
atteint enfin petit
un petit saut à votre ami kevin pour
aller voir sa chaîne fruits ce sont ceux
qui ne se qui ne connaissent pas il faut
aller voir nos chaînes respectives
souffre on a une aussi haineux puis
peloton mois et
du coup on sera très heureux de vous
retrouver sur nos chaînes respectives
donc n'hésitez pas à aller les voir ça
serait ce serait sympa et après au delà
de de les suivre ses chaînes c'est venir
nous voir et nous parler de vos
problématiques et chicken et on essaiera
de vous aidez moi je stream cinq fois
par semaine vous avez un planning sur la
chaîne et bastos il va vous dire ce qui
est ce qu'il fait prochainement souffle
at & t en reprise le stream
bah oui mais avec le tournoi là je n'en
ai plus lourd ça plus compliqué après de
stream de stream sur ma chaîne que moi
je fais tous les jours à la française
comme deux semaines
donc je vote mis de côté et aussi quand
vous avez pu le voir avec avec enfin
francesca hebinger des proies les
enfants de connexion internet si
vraiment horrible et donc ça m'aide pas
du tout pour le stream mais comme je
l'avais annoncé je serai bientôt de
retour
à une civilisation plus normal
vous aurez une connexion internet
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup mieux dans
cette version de les questions de
quelques semaines je pourrai le stream
est vraiment vraiment bien
depuis une connexion internet qui est
normal et
sain parce qu'on ferait on fera un total
look s'apprêtent une après mon frein
sommes battles et après un match par
semaine la totale et malheureusement
beaucoup venus parce que c'est la bonne
ambiance mais ça sera chaud moi je veux
le match d'ultra bullet aux propos kevin
et moi si je commence à te remettra
mieux que je garde une
phrase type speed chef du 5 1 points
mais
mais on fera pas le 1-0 parce que là là
ce sera le rasage intégral là j'aurai
plus de
1 plus 1 mais s'est laissé l'horreur
ça va
c'est très bien j'ai intérêt de faire
toute la différence 5 + 1 et 3 plus haï
de prendre vraiment la marche colonna
parce que je vais me faire raser de chez
raser un
non non je suis un bon client je pense
pour cette cadence
non non ça n'irait pas samana passer ça
serait ce serait la galère il a brûlé
mes tortues est très motivé pour ça on
prends la totale enfin la totale façon
phrase qui vous fait entre guillemets
plaisir mais on s'en passerait bien
aussi pas on se fera des trucs en forme
en tout cas ça va être sympa et pour les
stocks batal moi c'est mon prendre
effectivement diaries pour le chat pas
touche sa bille pas touche
c'est magique excellent mental ouais je
t'annonce
et shaun hill et m
et ils jouent très bien aux échecs mort
ce moment c'est un petit peu la crise un
peu comme comme
beaucoup de monde voit la crise qu'ovide
la crise covin est passée par là mais
mais mais j'avais pas
c'est qu'on prend pas touche je pense
que je pense que il bat en commun je
sais pas qui peut ramer le battre à
[Musique]
elle n'existe pas pour l'instant
par contre ce que j'ai pensé ça on
pourrait se faire une une une seule
battle en
problème ah ouais simple on peut faire
ça aussi merci tu fais parce que là pour
le coup je n'ai pas tout fait de
condamner et je pense qu'elle que tous
les poids et ben je me rends pas compte
je m'en rends pas compte des niveaux
mais
mais j'ai quelques maîtres qui peuvent
jouer mais je voudrais quand même aussi
jouer les gens du chat sont très
réguliers comme ça comme ça s'amuser cdc
sabbath a donc fait responsable s'est
livré moi j'ai des élèves qui sont
qu'ils sont sérieux 11h alors admis en
tout cas les gars oui
on a plein de choses à
moi vous savez on aime bien avec avec
stéphane passer les moments sur le char
ya un petit peu de temps en temps c'est
logique
où vivre ou revivre et du coup on va
peut-être quatre finales parce que
pour cette saison
[Rires]
ça c'était donc ça c'était
oui c'est vrai que
le principal sponsor de ma chaîne pour
l'instant c'est effectivement stoop donc
il ya du sens de la réflexion de ne pas
tout voilà
produits coquille vide alors je suis
désolé je vais devoir casser un petit
peu l'ambiance ah mais
oui c'est vrai
la poupe la paume la poupe est iap ont
déjà pensé tiens à penser en ce moment
arrive avant qu'arnaud
minty de rêver que ce soir non il est
pro 1 apparemment il est prompt à chaque
fois
on était pas du coup c'est toi qui a la
clé quasiment moi je vais vous lancez la
pub
vous voulez c'est sûr
ouais voilà je vais mettre un petit
rhume direct hausse alors alors ovo
amadeus honteux honteux l'expliquent dès
qu'on revient comment on fait pour top
santé mais il ya
tout qui a commencé à expliquer on s'en
lasser mais
on l'expliquait un petit peu après mais
en fait on a cherché des respectives
donc pour évoluer sur une flaque étouffe
et là on construit sur un autre chaîne
la pièce comme fr c'est pas mentionné
new perso en fait c'est la chaîne on va
dire de notre preview mes employeurs 1
parce que on se
réfère et en stream son roman le site
sur lequel on travaille en fait nous
voulons
donc voilà donc en tout cas en tout cas
on vous explique dès qu'on revient dans
six minutes exactement
donc restez avec nous pour tous et à
tout de suite a tout de suite
[Musique]
oh
je suis prêt et on est parti en est
reparti et on va aller voir du côté de
karuïa clean puisque pendant la pause
stop manie cost est hyper chaud
et la pression et déjà déjà pour dix
mois tout sauf bon oeil l'ouverture je
connais pas trop trop vite avait bien
sûr comme ça moi je vous la nouvelle
zone
j'étais un beau c'est un élève sur cette
ligne là un jeune tu vois entre 2001 et
2002 et il devait faire son fichier sur
sur fouquet quatre voies la f3 c'était
la demande du coup il a construit un
fichier et on avait regardé un petit peu
les parties parce que j'ai joué ça avec
les blancs pendant un moment le coût qui
était dans la théorie le plus joué c'est
celle des 5
et ensuite il y a eu tous les c5 qui
sont plutôt des grosses préparations
avec des noirs généralement puisque sur
des 5 tu vois il ya des choses comme b5
justement et c'est hyper tendu
dans cette pause ont réagi à l'est le
très fortement ça mais la grosse
pression sur le pion des cinq si on
prend ou a déjà les schémas se dégager
du coup eu 4 c'est le coût normal et des
six ça reste toujours en tension hyper
chaud sauf que champion devait bien
connaître je sais pas je ne pas
connaître tout la position ce que
faisait ne vous voyez que c'est quand
même assez atypique
bon il a joué à six ok c'est un peu fort
membres en cause pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas c'est à dire qu'on peut
jouer sur les pions à 2 à 2 et b2
perpétuellement donc ça va être ça va
être assez assez sympa normalement même
si on venait à perdre un pion on aura ce
qu'on appelle des compensations forte
positionnelle avec un triple enjeu de
pièces voilà la promesse des noirs
moi j'aime pas trop trop générale et
position avec f3 je t'avoue
je trouve que c'est un petit peu trop
ouvert à mon goût donc j'ai un très bon
ami donc pas touche tant de chat à lui
qui peut plus le temps d'être avec trois
dents contre tout
et on a fait des participants on a
beaucoup joué ensemble et en acquérant
des parts qui a toujours très sympa
destour de rentrer dedans sur les cases
noires et tout s'est compliqué mais en
tout cas je suis pas fan généralement
quand je vois cette position ben
visuellement on fait je tends sa bien
aimée les noirs en fait parce que j'aime
bien en fait d'essayer de tout cas c'est
ouvrir et oui je crois il avait ouvert
mais ça c'est question de france perso
un oui en pratique je pense que tu as
raison après les joueurs sont tellement
forts qui peuvent se permettre ce genre
d'excentricité sachant qu'en plus il ya
des et qu'on pense là en l'occurrence il
annonce qu'il va pas se faire ouvrir 2 3
au centre et que ça va devenir enfin
normalement ils prêts bancaires ou achat
en fait avec les blancs aller chercher
la petite cabane en h1 voilà et à quatre
c'est déjà une décision intéressante un
structurellement comment on fait pour
gérer ce problème une question qui est
posée sa force mais français puis là on
voit déjà le plan se dérouiller déroulé
à merveille
oui mais en pratique c'est vrai souvent
on n'aime pas jouer en pur f1 voyez des
joueurs comme comme norman attaché aux
jeux sur le long terme il dit que la
hollandaise c'est une mauvaise
d'ouverture parce qu'on touche le pion
avec quoi c'est qu'il y en a qui sont
plus des extrémistes encore que toit
souple tu vois en disant ça alors que
bon c'est quand même joué par des très
bons joueurs mais c'est un petit risque
c'est un petit risée je critique par une
loi juste je dis que j'aime pas
bien dans ses positions en fait on est
mais après oui c'est
bien et d'ailleurs car yakine
il a joué là dessus un clairement dans
ce sens ce choix puisqu'il a joué qu'à
et b17 il lâche le pion aux 6 c'était
fait exprès avec des cavaliers ou cinq
et on en voit déjà le problème d'avoir
joué f3 tapas la case naturel de ton
cavaliers donc ça retarde le
développement du cavalier j'ai un écart
yakine a essayé d'en profiter
jean-claude devait connaître ou prend
ses huit dames français 8 ok il faut
être quatre pour contrôler la case d3 et
ferme à la structure d'options peut-être
fou prend 1,5 à un moment c'est 4 bon il
ya toujours toujours
voilà on élimine
les pires voyage 3 à l'idée de ce tout
fait et en place avec fous ces 5 le
problème c'est qu'il ya de l'âme deux
cavaliers f2 tir potentiellement donc
faut réussir avec les noirs parce qu'on
a un peu de moi
il faut que ça marche cette histoire de
compensation sur les cases noires
enquête à me2 c'est logique tour mais
huit pression sur le pion mais deux
d'accord qu'un voilier f2 là je suis aux
portes du petit rock
c'est imparable de façon à hordain
bessette on a vu garde
alors du coup d'un bep cette gaffe
désolé pas tous ches
patoijeux modérait
j'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu la madeleine si
on veut dire que là il a osé dire que
dès lors que le bo landaise est toujours
mieux que la fidi d'or
s'est passé quoi non mais c'est normal
c'est normal tu sais que c'est ce qu'on
aime c'est ce qu'on ait lieu d'être
aussi
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on aime j'ai tout essayé
compagnie mise au jeu ça reste mieux que
la wii alors du coup
pourquoi dame mais ça ne vient
pas parce qu' ils menacent pas vraiment
j'ai cru que quelque chose n'a pas été
joué
dans la saga tout vous dire j'ai vu rock
aussi est sûre d'un promet de je pensais
qu'il y avait
il ya vait tour b 1
j'ai passé ça mais en fait il ya d'un
point d'eau et surtout premiers huit
échecs sans doute 3,17 quelque chose
comme ça et là tout reste en l'air
c'est quand même intéressant de voir ce
qui se passait sur tours bien mais aussi
les foules prime deux
tours bien c'était pas c'était un calcul
est donc d'un me 2
c'était le bazar
il a tourné huit intermédiaire c'est ce
que je voulais faire vous voyez un petit
coin intermédiaire je pense qu'ici a
simplement roi 17 avec l'impact de la
tour
et être fou des quatre qui peut arriver
de plus ont passé j'ai pas plus que les
pièces moi je n'aime pas forcément si
bien pas être des pièces d'or
oui mais là j'ai joué ça vraiment pour
faire une tactique qui ne fonctionne pas
à quoi donc
dame prend b2 en fait j'ai encore il a
juste cassé le pion sk c'est marrant je
trouve finalement le roi c'est le roi
noir en fait le
dindon cette position et la carrière
green il avait vu de cette position
instance il avait fait confiance à juste
fou prend un ou deux qui gagne une pièce
ce que sur tout problème de vous voyez
tous d'un point sauf que la championne
il avait prévu quelque chose brault h 1
ok j'ai une pièce en moins mais qu'est
ce que tu fais maintenant des menaces
tour b 1 dames 6 échecs le fouet f2 et a
taclé dont il a considéré qu'il avait
assez pour faire mal ici champions mais
d'ailleurs ça se vérifie ce qui a eu des
mots b3 et maintenant
madame cécile
mais alors gardez dame sait si je compte
pas ça si claire et 300 et surtout grand
fourre tout racheter vite souffle si je
dis pas de bêtises
c'est pas des faits qu une tête d'homme
6,6 pour bnp
madame c6 relève 7
on a bougé de calcul est aveugle a
normalement faire comme les joueurs
tomber 1
en tout cas ça reste hyper chaud cette
position y'a rien de
rien
bon tout de mettre un bon athlète 525
aussi je sais pourquoi souffre parce
qu'il m'avait perles et hier j'ai fait
un apéro oublie de saccades sur la sur
la chaîne et du cou
en fait on s'est fait raser les mecs sur
chasse comme ils sont hyper fort les
pères qu'on joue et
faire ça franchement ces points ce n'est
pas que de la peau de chat 125 beaucoup
comme un camp quand il a joué avec moi
bien sûr tu imagines bien mais non
franchement les pères qu'on a joué les
clc folle
et jolie paire bien les mecs
très bien en fait nous quand on joue
dans un club on se croit le roi du monde
mais en fait non on est juste
il faudrait qu'on fasse ça aussi une
démonstration 2005 à d'envoi une team
sous faut voir si c'est si c'est vrai
avec s'emploie obama mais tu sais que
j'avais moi j'avais beaucoup joué à
l'époque en bout de sa quête en fait
c'était plutôt en crise yahoo ce en un
contre un que j'avais beaucoup joué oui
la vie et j'avais j'avais try hard
pendant des années des années ouais et à
un moment donné sur la survie chess gt
gt top 10 pendant très longtemps
vainqueur de milan - l'eau
dans les airs il ya peut-être sept huit
ans avec waka et j'étais trop chaud en
crédit aux essais mais là ça n'a rien à
voir
c'est un point
donné on vieillit mal de choses
en fait il ya il ya il y a theory par
entaille à la théorie d ouverture est en
fait en craignant que la théorie elle
est pas valable on ne garde
nationale sur héroïquement est en fait
en fait par exemple moi je sais que
quand on joue en
équipe donc deux contre deux normalement
il faut par ok ça mais
je m'en suis aperçu avec mes pions à
chis qui vient inquiéter de défonce tout
ton rock etc est ce que ça veut dire que
tu ressors de gagner tous ses matches
avec 525 ça c'est pas sur un sketch à
525 hier il était 1 il était fatigué
fatigué en fin de semaine pour lui
du coup du coup ils essaient je pense
qu'il essayait de me faire perdre le
souffle je pense que c'est ça il est
venu pour ça et il a réussi son coup tu
as une victoire une défaite ça passe
chez 525 comme il le dit dans le tchat
c'est bon ça à ton tour est qui et qui
vient d'arriver
beaucoup de facéties dans le chat très
clairement du coup on n'a rien et lisse
il est là on n'a pas dit comment
champions didier jouer donc dame sait si
son propre aux rois f7 et là il faut pas
d'être précis bon ben là on a notre
avantage c'est a disparu complètement
donc c'était déjà pas d'âme ses six
qu'il fallait jouer apparemment peu on
peut réfléchir à ce qu'est ce qui s'est
passé il ya pas encore la page windham
ses 6,1 dame b 3 qu'est-ce qu'on peut
jouer c'est madame c6
dur dur déjà
c'est vrai
quand le coup qui fait mal
j'ai vu tout à l'heure dans notre chatte
quelqu'un qui proposait de même ses sets
je sais pas c'était s'était pas je sais
pas si tu es à ce moment là mais c'est
monstrueux comme c'est cette main
de dame celle je me laisse le pion aux 5
et surtout discrètement tour b 1
oh
comment tu fais trouve sur dame c7
validez tourbe est un juste tourbe et un
combiné
et en fait j'ai d'emprunt 5 de secours
j'ai vu dans l'achat de là
moi c'est pas grave règne t on 58 bosser
voilà c'est bien mieux que beaucoup un
tueur est largement en étant joueur de
club de toute façon meilleure que
beaucoup de la population et chicken
mondiale mais oui
c'est vrai que mon 58 normalement tu as
une marge tu vas gagner des points
moment suivant nos stream et autres n'y
a pas d'inquiétude et sache aussi
qu'avec ce mouvement disait on a
expliqué dans d'autres stream et on a
démarré les échecs tout petit et la
quasi totalité des joueurs de haut
niveau tu vois encore sûr de haut niveau
à c'est toute proportion gardée mais
tous les joueurs à plus de 2200 aux
échecs généralement ils ont commencé
très tôt c'est c'est pas vrai pour tout
le monde mais peut-être 90% voire donc
je pratique d'autres disciplines où j'ai
pas commencer à 88 5 ans comme génie
pour les échecs et ben je galère plus je
galère plus
voilà donc
d'imbéciles sur dame c'est celle de
passes touche ouais vous avez proposé
mais on m'a pas entendu je l'avais dit
que la vanille mobile
d'un prêt
avec l'idée tour bien toujours pareil
c'était mon 1.522 secours qu'est-ce que
vous jouez après donc d'un point 5 royal
je pense
donc ces cinq
dames ces cinq dames ces cinq dames 5
une foire nomme 5,2 fois
ci des cavaliers des 5e et de secours
aussi
les 5-6 tu prends bien je reprends mais
j'ai tourné sept on va vous montrer je
pense comme ces sept c'est le coup sert
logique
et mon avantage a dégringolé un petit
peu mais je garde le pressing je vois
pas le coup
autrement
donc on a dix dames mais six dames 5 au
wave tête
et lâche proposé tomber un nouveau en
espérant faire la différence et
apparemment ce n'était pas un coup
l'année dams et 5 et je voulais jouer
qui a aidé 5
eh ben on voit que là je me dis que je
n'avais pas raison
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai ratés avant
j'ai raté le coche apparemment ce n'est
pas si facile cette position il dit
qu'on est archi archi gagnant et je vous
à elle vous avouer que je ne trouve pas
je trouve pas ça si simple je pensais
que dams et 7 c'était la clé
visiblement non
alors qu'est ce on peut jouer dans cette
position comment on va gagner
d'un principe d'un moment si je vois pas
du tout qu'est ce que j'ai comme tout
candidat est ce que sous fais ce que tu
as une idée là je suis en galère dans
cette position pour pour comprendre
pourquoi on m'annonce que je suis
gagnant est
peut-être que j'ai simplement d'un
projet 7 en fait un meilleur apport
suite
c'est celle là en vie dans cette salle
n'a envie
c'est
quoi
on vous rappelle qu'on calcule son
ordinateur c'est mieux
[Musique]
mais je le vois pas du tout hein
et c'est pour ça que co champions il va
avoir du mal ainsi on trouve pas un
scoop
[Rires]
ça serait très étonnant qu'ils trouvent
non mais en fait il ya peut-être rien de
passer
ça doit pas être si facile que ça sinon
on aura trouvé la langue galère en
galère on peut le dire mais c'est pas
peut-être que j'ai simplement en fait
d'un essai 7 d'un bassiste d'un province
en cavale et wyatte et cavaliers ça
parce que la dame comme v6 attention il
faut défendre f2
non attends j'ai failli y proposer un
coup
horrible ça marche pas du tout je crois
moyen
pacifique avait des cinq direct sans
tomber à
son tour bpt un
rapproche de la victoire en 3d cheikh
mc 6 tout va bien soit défense
royer
dams et
6.7
tomber m
[Musique]
au pire j'ai pas tout de suite
c'est un peu beau jeu là mais
pour acheter vite allez hop c'est pas
peur
et si honda hm france et 8 dans le
premier 1 c'est vrai que tu veux faire
marcher qu'est ce que tu veux on s'évite
secura stouff
d'apprendre mesdames csn revient
le roi bouge et je crois
avec de cavale par exemple
souviennent qu'ils copient là on n'est
pas d'accord
je chantais qui est un petit coup qui
dans l'histoire
j'arrive après je n'ai pas gagné
5,26 et
le savent à quoi viennent de le chat
soit 125 est ce qu'on l'a relais ou pas
le beaujolais et beaujolais
voilà déjà il sait pas distinguer à 8 59
voix il distingue en blague
en plus des jeunes arrivent pas ils nous
aident pas pour la position tu vois lui
fait des blagues il dit allez tiens
alors et sam il a joué dame csn
bah franchement oui il ya marqué très
bon coup donc du coup sa nouvelle le
coup a trouvé bon c'est le coup qu'on a
regardé
le plus longuement quasiment mais on n'a
pas réussi à trouver
sur
sur ce coup comment continuer d'un v6
proposé par stouff qui était un
excellent coup de dépenses
le seul coup ça va être jouée dans la
partie je pense
hélas avec les généraux pour le madex a
demandé alors pour sa part déjà à mad
movies le seul
c'est celle là c'est pas la nôtre laon
stream sur cèze comme
mais on a nos prochaines années donc les
chaînes de là on les a on les a publiées
sur le stream sur le tchat pour
s'abonner simple tu vois en dessous de
l'écran en dessous de la page et marquer
s'abonner en violet du dessus il faut
rentrer étaient coordonnées soit paypal
soit bancaire et puis tu
ta bonne quoi hein mais en fait en gros
ça c'est assez simple mais met donc donc
du coup les soldes battaient le confort
avec kevin tout ça il faudra être abonné
donc ça coûte ce passé 4e maintenant 4
euros par mois ou pas tout vous voulez
on pouvait la bonne hectares où voulez
vous enlever quand vous voulez
aucune pression non mais l'idée c'est un
soutien des gens qui triment est en fait
un c voilà c'est ça essentiellement
oui il a raison
cherche le ko et faut être lucide des
pointes à une position qui sent le ko et
finalement comme tu l'as vue là on a
cherché parce que c'était intéressant
mais il n'y avait pas donc pour jouer la
vente qui concerne le plus davantage
je pense que ça va être ça la partie est
et ça me chante landes il a une position
très intéressant mais je pense que la
jauge nous nous alors j'ai envie de voir
est ce qu'il y avait vraiment un gain
sur dames mettra parce que finalement
dame certes c'est le coup qu'on avait vu
ce qu'ils avaient vraiment un gain non
en fait c'est la geôle des fois
compte
elle raconte des bêtises et du coup j'ai
vérifié c'était bien dames c'est celle
de meilleurs coûts qu'on a un but
clairement sauf que la geôle elle tombe
et ça des fois ça le fait assez souvent
je pense qu'on va voir d'un v6 d'un sac
voilà et je vous annonce ça va être ça
la suite de la partie bref dette et la
championne il va chercher parce que ça
sent bon mais en même temps on n'a pas
réussi on a galéré dans cette position a
trouvé quelque chose de concret et c'est
de ma faute d'ailleurs
j'ai vu ici souffre du coup en mettant
dams et c'est ce qu'indique et j'ai fait
tour bien ou un plaid teneur de ces cinq
sites de ma part il faut jouer qui a
aidé 5 directement à ce que disait
t'as pas mais six voix là t'as pas le
cas avant parce que là j'ai tour sert en
fait
il va retrouver confiance il va trouver
je pense que karim est en difficulté
parce que c'est assez logique tout ça
déjà surnomment ses 7 il doit être
embêté car yakine
si vous voyez un la caméra d'une façon
qui n'est pas n'est pas serein
non mais c'est vraiment une partie
intéressante là qu'on a
c'est peut être la partie la plus
intéressante jusqu'à présent
sur les autres espaces moins de
moins de beau jeu là c'est vraiment
juste pour info dans le challenger arjun
hariri ghazi a fait nul contre nguyen
s'assurant le tournoi cadets mandat il
assure la wii n'a donc là il a il a un
point et demi d'avancé sur l'adversaire
et il ya bien jonah ce qui qui a sept et
demi doit gagner les deux dernières et
que eric à y perdre demain fin donc c
est remettre
les gaz y perdre demain avec les noirs
contre marc-andré ya failli perdre
demain et que paris fasse deux sur deux
donc traitement quand même pas mal de
réussite donc et ça ce serait pour que
regarder soi égalité avec avec bière
messi se passera tout ça est gazé sera
quasiment sûr de gagner pour moi
donc il a raison enfin
contre les guerres et à style
masters c'est quand même camatte coup de
ouf un produit donc c'est une
opportunité donc là nulle rapide
allaient complètement comprendre ce et
je pense que tout sépare et
fils la qualif
on va attendre d'avoir la réponse de
karuïa qui n'ont peut-être retourner
voir magnus ou
où il ya une autre partie qui
t'intéresse peut-être particulièrement
alors voilà j'ai pas fais pas trop
quelle plus tard
car c'est bien là on est pas sûr qu'on
n'est pas allé voir et
puis moi je pense car sans savoir ce qui
se passe
à cannes pour qu'on voit notre ami
magnus on va pas le mans beaucoup
voilà
avec désespoir ouais
serein
et voilà
ok
donc
déjà donc c'est une 6ème variante
rossoni mots du grand classique
jusqu'ici on s'attendre à clamer les
deux on peut jouer four 3 évidemment sa
menace interne pions le pion ces cinq
cd cd a été déjouée d'un v6 pour
demander aux fous de se positionner
mettre la pression sur b2 dames 1 2 et
et jouer une défense des deux pions visé
par fouet pions visée ou 17
il peut y avoir des des petites
thoracique
exemple cavaliers prend 1,5 linedata
qu'une du fourbe et
5.4 a été joué
ne marchent le plus parce qu'ils
allaient prendre des parents et la dame
se retrouve attaquer donc j'ai pas le
temps de manger le fou le choix à quatre
tours à ses huit dont les noirs sont
logiques développe tous les pièces d'eau
cahier c3 avec les blancs c'est normal
pour se développer on voit aussi calme
et d'une passion et en plus si elle puis
en l'air mais surtout l'idée
on ce qu'un pion de faibles mais on
densifie complètement le centre
du coup ça peut être hyper intéressant
derrière dans ce type de position
d'aller chercher le roi noir on va voir
ce qui va se passer
et autrement une autre idée ça peut être
un jour de jouer pour ces 4 s'est séparé
de cette faiblesse non madame des 8 a
été le jouet
pour laisser éventuellement des
possibilités de cavalia 5 lorsque le
fouetter en l'air donc ça fait passer
sur la case d'avant-postes échangé
contre le fu proposer les changes vous
avez trois cavaliers à cinq ils arrivent
sur la case d'avant pas c'est logique
tours s'est en plus je tu as le plan c
est la
plus étonnant
magnus le choix d' enlever le fou mais
trois mais il rétablit la structure de
plusieurs angles il a par deux fois
puis la part de fou mais sûrement tôt
mais là aussi un potentiel de compass et
avec b 5 à 5 à 4
non madame b 6
damas deux à cinq le coût proposé par
souffre en tout cas l'idée de valoriser
ses pions
d'un match a été joué pour mettre la
pression sur cette tour est peu vite ok
et maintenant il faut regarder aussi les
programmes c4 1 parce que si il est
clair que manu c'est la paire de fou est
un pion passé potentiel où une majorité
avec le deux contre un qui a indiqué ici
ben pourquoi pas essayer de faire ces
cadres
ont valorisé le centre parce que les
blancs ils ont en contrepartie de la
majorité elle dame la peur de foudre
majorité centrale
ou en tout cas un pion c'est qui peut
permettre de me lier le centre qui va
conduire à une majorité centrale
lorsque ne veut pas faire caruana je
pense qu'il réfléchit aussi à cela c'est
d'ouvrir tous les cases blanches pour le
foot 15 branches de magnus même temps il
faut bien faire quelque chose dans cette
position se trouve madame et
oui c'est normal c'est normal
essayez de 2
d'ouvrir les cases blanches on est chaud
je trouve ça normal je devrai alors
cavaliers d2
et là je pensais à éviter aussi alors
peut-être si lisa
mais humide et avec à 4 en fait
parce que oui je suis comme ça
j'aimerais bien vraiment prête voyez que
après parmi ces quatre pouces et 6 eh
ben j'ai pas vraiment manger avec les
noirs en c4 à cause de bay prend ses 4
il y aura un fort centre blanc qui me
qui m'empêcherait de vraiment m'activer
mais fou alors que s'il plombé
disparaissait je pourrai manger en c4
avec mon pions et après j'aurais une
case confortable pour mon fou en d5 qui
serait très fort sur le plan qe2 et du
coup l'idée c'est qu'une fois qu'ils
jouent ces 4 il est un peu comique parce
que
le pion il avançait déjà et du coup
après comme à 4 eh bien je devrais
choisir un peu quoi faire parce que tous
les jours son rapport aux prises le plan
b est en prise options cette emprise
et
savannah intéressant c'est par ce pape a
répondu ainsi que fait-on déjà j'avais
tour à 8 mais surtout tu laisses
fonction c'est trop en l'air
en a et du coup faire attention parce
qu'après il plombe être aussi qui tient
tant l'air mauvais vieux ceps doc ckd
causé 6 donc j'aime beaucoup l'idée ces
femmes parce qu'il valorise les cases
blanches
si je prends mais j'ai pas à faire je
vais pas faire ça je vais proposer quel
est le champ chill
je voulais faire c'est saint caprais sûr
ton idée car c'est à dire que je suis à
quatre et c5
et si je fais un comme damas et si tu
veux jouer à quatre où je comptais fixé
avec b prend à tour mais un
et ça
pour que tu es la seule faiblesse de
l'échiquier
en fait j'ai pas réussi activement fou
quoi ça qui me vient manger à quatre
avec madame archipel changé j'ai chou
blanc mais tout vient c'est vraiment
énervant parce que tu vas être obligé
sans doute de
m'être fou puis après en plus mon
cavalier ça casse c'est à 5 et pouvoir
venir à laval et b3 fou des deux
cavaliers à saint quentin
la tour avant mais mais mais c'est ça la
problématique je vais réussir à attaquer
le pion stefanki qui le pion un peu plus
elle s'il est pas ce problème là il
serait mieux avec le pion mais ces six
là à la base si je mets ce sont là ici
la faiblesse de l'option sur
sur colonne semi-ouverte un pion
arriérés et isolées là il y aura des
fous et 5 et le foot case blanche serait
monstrueux mais c'est pas le cas pour
l'instant alors du coup
sûr le cavalier d'eads apparemment
cavaillé d2 j'ai vu la juge mais c'est
je pense que sur fos et 6 peut-être je
dois déjà joué c5 c6 est pas si clair
dans mon esprit
dans ce cas là je sais pas j'avais 4 ans
et je dois jouer ces cinq parce que je
peux faire un clone amadeus maintenant
amadeus son option n'est plus en l'air
et peut-être que je peux mettre du monde
sur le pion à saint-claude souffre hélas
que je vous donnais à 6 un jour je
pourrai pas être
pessimiste cmp auprès
tour un matin le temps de faire b6
prise d'empreintes des 3ème et gb 4
salaire de mieux pour
mes quatre à quatre
passer la main ou alors je m'énerve pas
et je fais food et le
maïs
je peux faire d'un procès aussi domaine
des français c'est bien pour la case des
quatre points cavale
j'ai pris l'option pour amener le
cavalier en déca vous voyez
quand même les blancs qui pour l'instant
ouais surtout reif 8 millions il faut
jouer ses cartes vraisemblablement parce
que c'est le pion faible
j'ai mes pions qu'il gêne à manaus pour
faire toi et taper sur 1,5 du coup je
fais c4 et givet quoi
voilà il ya une bosse ecoute-moi samassa
me réjouis tout ça je n'aime pas trop
khanaqinne
donc tu l'histoire la date de valeur
depuis le début
voilà et donc du coup
le champ clos
cette position jusqu'au réfléchir il n'y
a pas beaucoup de coups pour pour
caruana s'il veut faire quelque chose de
cette position c'est plutôt c4 je pense
va devoir le c4 surtout qu'en plus
alors je sais pas si à 4 au final ça va
finir pas à coup de menaces parce que si
jamais imaginons je vois je crois je
pourrais dire eh bien en fait sur h3
est-ce que je peux jouer ici à 4 c'est
ma question parce qu'en fait si je peux
jouer à quatre dans des bonnes
conditions s'appelle d'un genre surtout
on prend des détours c4est m'activer
d'après toute attaque c'était aussi la
colonne b 127 donc c'est pas sur un mais
l'idée en fait je viens jouer avec le
plombier partie eh ben le pion c3i les
arriérés il ya bientôt raitt dans ces
quatre il ya plusieurs idées et moi je
n'ai jamais forcé quatre plutôt bienvenu
parce que tous les candidats trois
points à 8
5 dans de bonnes conditions pour moi tu
as à un coq et je n'ai pas bien ça dans
ce cas là peut-être que tu auras ville
du coup oui mais en fait l'idée par
l'idée j'adore l'idée parce que tu nous
montres sous peu
nouveau coup de quinze manches devient
monde son idée il faut pas donner un peu
en dessous qui veulent récupérer un brel
le couple passait par là et puis je veux
soul et l'adversaire avec son fou de
cases blanches c'est le seul à l'avoir
ouais ouais bon foule m'a placé dans la
position initiale et du coup j'aimerais
si j'aimais déjà qu'elle va enlever le
pion b3 et ben je me crée des des casses
pour ce fou et du coup le pion ces trois
bains devient arriérés parce que vous
voyez là le veut le poste 3 avril voir
du mal à avancer et s'il ya un pion
blanc b3g mon petit copain d'ailleurs
une fois que son c4 dans mon genre autre
handicap donc il est dévié sur le plan
des faux pas des bilans mais après faut
réussir à faire aussi un
mois je suis père parti ak aq illégale
car hakim prague là c'est partiel
oui on en tournait un prêt serait genou
et je vais mettre un petit damas six
dames c6
faites un à terme et à bessat qui est
plus faible que que ces trois en tête en
pratique c'est pas simplement nous c'est
compliqué de cette position l'idée
l'idée avait bien je pense fin je pense
qu'arsène d'être resté trop de chercher
un truc de ce type là mais en pratique
c'est vraiment dur à mettre en place
pour l'instant on n'a pas trouvé
pas le choix dans la structure mais vous
voyez c'est très important parce que au
niveau la différence on a 100 sur le jeu
avec les pions ils sont très malins
avec ces décisions de pions qui
modifient
positivement ou à la négative votre
position donc c'est hyper important ce
côté là de bien jouer ses pions sam
valorisera vos pièces et ses 4 c'est un
excellent coup pour se libérer de cette
faiblesse en c3 la patience et saint
caprais de travail et les purs adverse
il perd bien joué
ok du conte alès parti chez mon petit
prono stouff match nul
sans quoi votre ligne loi qui signent
des feuilles on y va direct on y va
direct et ça s'est fini ultra
wilaya qui
aie aie aie aie aie aie excuse moi mais
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
le célébrer cette victoire alors un
conseil
ils sont allé aussi vite parce qu'on
avait pronostiqué hockey
watch en était là d'un bep trois dames
c'est cette île a trouvé d'un v6
d'emprunt
jusque là on avait parlé d sur wave
c'est ton avis faut pas jouer tour béa
qui est tentant ou profiter de la dame
en v6 free qui a élevé cinq mais on ne
voyait pas la défaite aussi rapide 2
cariat clint kent francs des fautes dans
mon dessin qui veut pas jouer de la main
cette dame cinq cantons a dû tacler
jusque là broyé f-16 et il a fait tour
c1 et pourquoi c'est à mon nom direct
puisqu'on a des tours sans vie constitue
jaya y aie aie aie aie aie aie
donc je ne peux pas jouer pour ces 8 à
cause de tour en tour prend et d'un
médecin qui clignotent et qui gagne une
tour 17 qui empêche les sept chez cette
menace qui est important tombé c'est
devant des produits partout on va devoir
faire travailler un petit peu
atex d'amd 5 us échec et de tours c6
qu'elle a pas mal aussi bravo souffle
très fort
surtout metz a dû souvent en tournée
cette dame des cinq là
comment on fait quand ce tour c'est 6
donc je fais pas je fais un coup je peux
aller en huitième rang j'essaie à tour
ses 8 donc je fais 3 e set il fait
toujours ses 6
elle est enfin là on prend tous les
coups du tennis là je vous laisse
d'abord
c'est rare que kayak mine sombre comme
ça
non mais il a mal évalué quelque chose
enfin pour revenir quand même pour vous
remonterez l'action de jeu
s'il y avait une position comme celle là
et
sur un coup anodin il a perdu cette
partie où il pouvait jouer peut-être
foot et 4 continuer le projet du
pressing étouffer la vulve idée agressif
dame bessette se disent est super malin
et sur petit rock il avait vu que son
pion ses cartes étaient en l'air mais
s'est dit ben hamdan promet il avait
calculé jusque là peu près en disant ma
position et elle n'est pas bonne pour
les blancs puisque sur d'un procès
quatre je vais faire comprendre et je
serai bien en fait un gros machin sans
doute que je calcule et là les principes
ans un terrible mois je pense que
que carla qui nie les ducs accueille ce
que dame b 3 il se dire que ça allait et
je pense qu'il a pas vus dames c'est
cette
ce que tu dis souffre effectivement du
calcul plus d'âme ses six ici de loin
modèle parce que c'est super calculette
les mecs l'échec intermédiaire voir que
ça ne donnait rien après rouaf 16 et du
coup il a oublié ce coup dams et 7 ou la
menace pour bella et ultra pénible
et sur d'imbéciles d'emprunt 5 très
bonne intuition le champion n'est tous
un très beau calcule aussi le fck et d5
terrible
et le roi est dans les clous
ça fait un peu comme jean planque qui
qui revient on ne serait pas l'attendre
là
surtout car iakounine a mal à voir
c'est un gros coup d'arrêt gros coup
d'arrêt pour carey a clean
donc c'est là que ma victoire de 100
kilos à chaque fois il avait perdu me
dit tu es perdu guiry
et fait du tout le reste s attendre à un
nul dans cette partie puisque 1 carat
qui ne restent très solides avec des
préparations théorique et ben là il
s'est fait avoir
pas facile donc voilà donc demain on
aura champlan il aura les droits des
noirs couronne forest et kaya khimki tu
as 6 sur 12 à la moyenne avec une
défaite aussi penco
et contrechamps clan du cou et une
victoire contre roanne forest ainsi que
contre prague dan dah on aura demain car
à kinect et blanc contre eux bill gates
et les pinceaux au moment de ce qui a
été obligé de prendre dès 5h visiblement
non parce qu'on a vu la largeur se
soulever en train guillemets mais non
mais ça fait peur quand adam en l'air et
adams et le soutien du fonds f2 donc
c'est dur de trouver un coup dans cette
position
parce que si tu perds le fouet dont on
considère qu arrive et le pion de moins
pas perdu donc tu dois trouver une autre
solution que cela et c'est vraiment
vraiment pas évident quoi
salut à toi au lit tôt non mais
franchement fallait trouver un coût mais
mais quoi
ce que sur dame c5
tu prends tour c'est un
donc tu avais le choix entre damas est
et dames des cartes des jeux comme ça
pour rester au contact
et ça pouvait être
très très chaud ma cette étape ducalcon
existe déjà et
est
plein d'échec aussi un
non c'est pas ça bonjour dans la halle
saint lô
peine position de rêve mais bon c'était
encore
encore jouable
on voir sur damas est est-ce qu'on a un
truc fort
allez tour sert toujours à téjédor
pourquoi il veut regarder mais je vais
trouver après
ces cavaliers 4 mais il fait roi g6
qu'on a chez c'est pas sûr qu'on
a une grosse faute et prend des cinq
sceaux est clair parce qu'il veut il
veut lui faire jouer un coup de plus
comme au tennis on fait jouer un coup de
pouce à l'adversaire dans une position
un peu
ému très facile pour leur dis mais
l'issue est humainement
c'est pas facile
franchement
et c'est pas les départs pour preuve
deux empreintes avaient eu d'annoncé 7%
cavaliers pour ce roi décide alors
cavalli eu cette
belle idée de ce qui nous fait donc tous
réunis
ils jouent dams et 7
avec l'idée
de jouer avec empathie dans le set c'est
le printemps mais souffre il a joué de
dams et c'est times il s est passé le
permis de7 bravo
avec un malien
donc il faudra bien droit
donc roger six cavaliers du coup aux
recettes pour avoir quasiment classe 15
9 5 et sur oasis illégale et f5 sur oise
gsm dorada me transcende
airwatch
5.356 mieux
y en a même un qui toujours
[Musique]
six
jours - ça
arrive après when the system chaud
maintenant c'est intéressant car si
tu comprends ouais mais ça m'a comment
maria tour g1 qui arrive maintenant si
j'aime à tous et n'est plus moi en fait
je peux manger une fois et varois jeta
ouais ça aussi ouais je te songez pas
besoin
en plus je suis kovalev 5
ça m'a l'air sensés bah ouais pas de
problème beaucoup de menaces tac
ok bon ça c'est complètement perdus mais
oui le courant en fait
trop froid ou de manger plus de coups il
faut que je joue quand même tout huit
envoyé que y avoir un problème je peux
je suis protégé ma tour et c'est ok c
voilà ce qu'il aurait pu jouer car
yakine ces fameuses pour moi
il pouvait jouer sa
bande des quatre mais bon
ça gratouille d'un petit monde c'est
quand même un âne à
ok il a raté vraiment cette
cette idée là j'avais encore pour 5 à 20
pour sada prend des 5 tours 7
[Musique]
en fin de tour 6 1 je te faire rager
8,6
est bon
on doit tenir cette position fait on
doit essayer de tenir sa nature mais pas
impossible parce que peut-être ça
vous voyez mon il y avait encore du
boulot hein en tout cas souffre mais
on voit que le kayak line il a lâché
mentalement il n'est pas prêt kayak lis
un peu son problème il est très bien
préparé mais je pense que ça doit le
rendre malade vu son talent de rater des
choses clairement il a oublié dames
c'est celle ils ont évolué il a habité
direct
peint aussi combatif qu'il aurait pu
l'être à un certain moment de sa
carrière
s'en
fout mais même à l'est moins
moins combatif
c'est
moi aussi
ok on bouge
on doit pas trouver aussi vite des
choses que cariat qui n'a pas vu c'est
un super talent il a essayé dans la tête
et là on voit qu'il avait clairement une
une position à thonière effectivement
elle était dans il était dans le dur
mais ça jouer quoi donc ouais c'est
dommage quand tu dommage
on va aller les voir d'autres partis
maintenant qu'on a vu celle là
est ce que je gagne un seul petit champ
clan de batagaï acti non non non je
gagnais pas de saab n'était pas prévu au
programme du coup main on n'a pas été
voir guy en avant
thierry grandet lieu peut-être
allez-vous leur dire bonjour quand même
moment devant jours avant la pub allez
on leur dit bonjour à mon un pub et
on va voir que et aguerri qui a copié le
style de magnus magnus il adore jouer
les débuts catalan attention là c'est
c'est une variante prince temps de l'ès
l'indienne la grande fête puisque les
noirs ont fait un flop les taux voilà et
nous on fait un triangle et aussi donc
ce sont les ventes positionnelle pour
traiter grünfeld estrade ya donc ces six
tout à fait jouable idc des singles on
mixe une sorte de de slaves et le
système chantier tôt ça s'appelle le
système néo grenade voilà pour votre
gouverne mais on voit surtout l'idée
c'est de tenir le centre par un pion et
de garder du coup le centre
on voit qu'il a retardé le projet de
geri tout de suite pour faire d'autres
choses et il a décidé de faire un schéma
avec d'un b3 vide est assez simple en
fait de retarder fous je ne sais juste
pas avoir le temps de personnes se
démener 3 avec cet ordre de coûts on
tape les pions
des 5e et c'est dingue la dame est en
pleine crise c4 qui est un thème
récurrent
par exemple une position qu'on peut
qu'on peut voir si je vous fous j'ai
deux partis flamands que le cas et ac3
maladroit
dépensé 4 est vraiment embêtant et si
vous jouez cava lieux saints qui un
thème rigolo dans cette position sur un
marché c'est qui avalise les cartes avec
l'idée de taper le cavalier centrale
parce qu'on voit ça beaucoup dans la
catalane mais quand le fou et angers
cette attention l'idée de caroline 5
c'est de reprendre le pion c4 mais quand
le fouet leur gsm et ça marche moins
bien quoi vous voyez ces cavaliers g4
c'est hyper pénible donc dire il
connaissait par coeur là c'est vraiment
du basique pour lui et il a retardé le
naturel fou j'ai deux en faisant
cavalier c3 déjà bizarre
l'autre joue dessin qui en fait d'un bep
trois là on comprend en fait ils
comptent bien je vais fouiller deux pas
de souci mais il anticipe et le d5
adverse avec ce cavalier ces trois dames
b droit il permanent hyper malin cet
ordre de coups ça lui permet en fait ne
jamais craint de dépenser 4
petit khomeriki sont fous j'ai de la
pression grandit autour de ce qu'ils ont
des 5 et l'allant et lieusaint d'essayer
de faire des français dame france est
structurellement parlant c'est déjà
petit avantage blanc puisqu'on est dans
un début de jeu
où débute mieux le jeu fins d'ouverture
et j'ai ma majorité centrale ils sont
comporte pas de rousset 6 dans cette
position totalement on comprenait
c'était pour tenir des 5 mais vu le pion
à sauter dans des sacs contre le pion
ces mauvaises affaires ben c'est quoi
l'idée du procès si ce mariage je bloque
mon cavalier bits donc les avantages
petit un wave 500 pêche la construction
du centre local
petit ordre logique cadets b 17 400
pêche tous les baies 5 c'est vraiment un
contrôle de la position que visent les
blancs maintenant c'est ça va être la
leçon tour ses huit c'est intéressant
pour essayer de faire ces cinq jours
mais a toujours des 5
ok c'est vrai on voit que c'est durant
cette position en b5 b6 telle idée de a5
est sûr à prendre mais si j'ai toujours
ma majorité centrale j'ai ouvert ma tour
1 voilà tout ça c'est bien un jour
j'aimerais faire re 4 mon rêve
donc faut être quatre l'urgence de la
pause le fuxéen
ou aussi d'amener trois jours j'ai
quatre pas de souci bref 5 hélas il n'a
pas peur 4
ok il ajoute à ma 6e 4 c'est un coin
pour responsable je mets le point devant
le fou etc et du coup bas souvent en
fait tu veux
maintenant la dame assise ça m'a l'air
bien prendre l'espace ap al amal nous
aussi un ramassis saint germain tient un
problème enfin parce que je me dis mais
eux 4 je le fais tous les jours mais y'a
ka mali c5 en fait
c'est ça l'histoire parce que sinon là
je comprends bien sûr ce que ce que
disent ouf salaires on n'est pas obligé
en fait on pourra le faire un jour si
vous voulez sur le cap mais là c'est ton
temps je veux gagner le tempo souffre je
me suivre c'est quand même trop tentant
le mec qui cherchent des films donnent
le tempo enfin il ya cette magouille cas
et ses cinq voiliers avec le rayon hier
sur la dame et du coup je peux pas le
faire bon il avait vu donc bon les
joueurs ils voient tout tactiquement
voyez en fait la partie est plutôt
stratégique mais dans cette stratégie
dans ce dans cette valorisation du
centre blanc etc il peut y avoir des
petites choses tactiques quand même donc
à chis jeu propre à tous rêvent d un
c'était la pièce à activer les pièces
qui ne joue pas c'est le grand classique
grenet ça pour l'instant la partie de
guérissent un modèle pour vous c'est ça
fait partie des parties d'école que
j'aime beaucoup regarder avec vous c'est
cool un sou pour ça se comprend ça l'a
maintenue 5 il joue aujourd'hui guérie
mais il est tout à fait capable de jouer
avec joie la guérilla a pas de souci
mais il joue propre les échecs propre il
a réussi à avoir une majorité centrale
très rapidement je le pense vraiment
l'ouverture n'a pas été bien joué par
parents des lieux est d'ailleurs le
temps l'indiquent 1h05 pour lire et qui
jouent à la main et grands des lieux ce
qui te retrouves avec 28 minutes et là
il ya une décision stratégique
importante qu'elle ait des cinq
propositions d'un échange
hélas assez étonnamment mais on va
l'expliquer on va expliquer pourquoi
il fait cavaler bon dessin ce qui
ressemble à une faute structurelles sauf
que on voit ses marques et point
d'exclamation très bon coup on a quand
même les anodes comme ça et oui c'est un
hyper intelligent parce que on revient
dans une structure symétrique mais moi
j'ai madame vivante matour vivante sur
la colonne ouverte l'huile à 7 tours là
qu'on va s'empresser sans doute de
contredire avec tours c1 et si on
regarde les autres pièces à ce cavalier
17 c'est la pièce la plus nulle de
l'échiquier pour l'instant il n'a pas de
case quasiment pour revenir et si en
plus il vient même si j'aurais cavaliers
5 donc là gros coup avec ses pièces
et ce psy on l'a qui est sous pression
ça promet c'est déjà dur on va voir ce
qui va jouer le dire il a un coût
important à trouver
j'ai envie de faire tour c'est un pas
sûr que ce soit meilleur coup mais j'ai
envie de continuer le pressing peut-être
d'un bep 5 on va tourner autour de la
broye maintenant
on sait bien on a là on a deux options
et si avec les blancs meilleure position
meilleur tour je pense à un bon petit
pressing pour le blanc de bien jouer
dans la tour
pas touche avait trouvé le 4 cavaliers
c5 dont le fait pas à pas touché non
ok donc sur ce
oui la petite pub la petite pub vous
savez ainsi mon voisin de pub donc voila
voila donc on vous dira tout de suite
pendant la question que tu as l'air de
de amadeus par rapport à viry après la
pub et
est donc rester parmi nous un atout de
suite les gars je vous envoie va plus
tout de suite
m
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
là
on est de retour avec ce tout pour les
commentaires et on voyait niels gron des
lieux sans grande difficulté un contrat
d'ingénierie est-ce que c'est toujours
le cas et ben oui ça change pas si
facilement
c'est dans cette position là on va voir
comment il va jouer comment il va jouer
tout ça mais c'est pas c'est pas évident
franchement j'aimerais pas être à sa
place et du coup on va revoir ça il a
fait ses premiers 5 et aniche il n'a pas
il n'a pas encore joué
preuve que c'est pas si facile il va
chercher à concrétiser son avantage et à
mon avis ça va être une torture torture
et ça va être très très très
très dur on voit que quand des le savent
1,8 à la pendule contre une heure c'est
difficile et
je pense qu'il va
salut à toi fils et à manier aussi m'a
bien fait marrer apparemment tu l'as
bien tu l'a scotché à son siège il
attend avec impatience la réponse sur
guy et sur le fait que ben il est il et
comment dirais-je le mal aimé du grand
public mais son fils aime bien
à chaque fois je me dis je répondrais la
pub parce qu'il faut qu'ils restent là
on a compris qu'il parte à quoi voir
mathieu cornette dès qu'on parle des
combats sans pub aidant c'est fini je
peux répondre toujours après d'appeler
votre toutes ces questions que je vais
garder pour pour la reprise c'est malin
donc pourquoi guy il n'est pas aimé en
fait tu diriges je pense qu'il est papa
et met enfin en fait c'est quelqu'un qui
adore [ __ ] la merde entre guillemets
sur les réseaux sociaux mais très taquin
très taquin et donc il va toujours se
moquer un petit peu des joueurs du même
de 40 scène un terrain même de lui-même
et en fait ils adorent troll sur twitter
un star absolue et du coup ben
il est tellement taga en fait que des
fois ça en devient un petit peu
tu vois
ce loup malsain et je pense que c'est
pour ça en fait qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ne l'aiment pas trop par
rapport à sa réputation oui les jusqu'au
boutistes dans les petites dans les
petits tacles quoi voilà mais après
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment amical
c'est pas si jamais vraiment un
karl scène est guéri il son pote acquise
la même par exemple s'est vu les
interviews de 2,40 scène après avoir bu
cas de victoire on la licra qu à
gillingham 4e d'affilée est en constante
à remonter il dit ouais bon après il a
si j'ai vu ce qu'il a dit mais genre en
gros il a plein de points gratuits et
cetera alors vaut mieux ne mérite pas
quoi comme ça ce tacle l'un et l'autre
et c'est tout a commencé en fait tu es
l'un et l'autre est un je crois qu'il a
reparlé de guiry je crois que c'était
hier dans l'interview il lui a dit que
20 de forrest venait de battre guiry ce
qu'il faisait ses affaires j'ai guéri
ses proches de l'eau au niveau du
classement et donc il ay l'exquis
sourire de l'or
et les riverains ont les deux joueurs
sont très taquin 30 août à cagliari et
du coup je pense il articule un champ
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui pensent
qu'il est sérieux quand tout ce qui est
dit alors quand il n'est pas sérieux il
est très très bas et très froid la voilà
on a eu la réponse est on voit changer
un petit mais jusque là en tout cas
il a beau être taquin pour l'instant il
est en pleine réflexion sur tout et on
va peut-être aller voir des partis qu'on
n'a pas trop eu
qu est ce qu a dit pères intéressant
c'est un moment qu'on n'est pas les voir
ont rapporté 6 points qu est ce qu il a
une position lui aussi de travail on va
aller voir ça parce que ça y ressemble
avec un rouge et s'être complètement
défaillante
c'est un peu du à green bay cette
injuste j'ai juste qu'on partait 1 il a
fait exprès j'ai vu jusqu en journée on
ira voir ça de façon mais on l'a attendu
on l'a attendu il n'a pas joué mais il a
continué le pressing donc pas
d'inquiétude par rapport à cela on y
retourne à une autre position de grosse
pression
richard rapport doit déguster pendant un
petit moment ça c'est sur ce qu'elle
fout g7 pas actif du tout et ce qu'il
veut faire c'est liquider les dames
vraisemblablement avec avec les noirs au
moins souffrir pour souffrir que d'un
côté de l'échiquier alors comment
garnotte retombées 5 qu'est ce qu'on
peut
pas si évident
peut-être d'un bessette d'un bessette
pardon
je serai bien même baisser a dit si
c'est parce que tu en penses tout fait
pour d un
ouais donc
je vais prendre
je crois que là dessous roi je pleurais
c'est ça le 4 way
je regardais moi je vous dis que j'avais
toujours
toujours le g3 de secours
tentaient de bouger les pièces contre un
petit peu aux jambes cette belle dame
messages laissés nous mettre la pression
sur b6 et surtout d'empêcher le dame
prend b5 qui voudraient appauvrir la
position est d'abord d'un point f 7,5
par rapport à cela c'est pour ça que je
nomme mais cette touffe bas il en
profite il n'y tiens je vais essayer de
mater
le gars kevin avec tournée 1
j'ai pris pour lui
en plus je regarde donc souf des
grillages
2,4 si vous voulez me faire des petits
guily comme ça beaucoup
ok
ladjouze qui n'est pas d'abord
oui mais il ya un problème je n'avais
pas vu enfin sur d'importants le cap
hume annoncé stéphane d'un premier 5
mais il ya quand même tour à 8 et tu vas
être obligé de battre c'est peut-être
coutu en fait puisqu'il existe toujours
donc je peux vous mangez sur 24
les tours à huit vous voyez il ya plus
roi un chad à cause de f 6 donc ça c'est
un gros problème est faux et ensuite on
n'a pas eu une saute au cloud et
parce que moi je pourrais à pied en fait
un
nom
madame vaisselle ça reste un coup de
pression il ya de bonnes chances pour
qu'ils le jouent dans cette position au
fait je viens de voir un instant la
victoire de jeu ne produisent indien
prada mandat
vient pas du tout de la voix mais ces
noms de ne faire ah ça vous le savez que
que ce souffle m'a même pas ce que
voulait
ainsi on avait dit quoi qu'il arrive
quoi qu'il arrive ça veut dire quoi
qu'il arrive donc souffler un gagnant à
sable sur la victoire par forfait de
diouf pour cause de kobe de quoi donc et
ils en gagnent pas beaucoup ne savent
souvent mais celui-là franchement c'est
un soft qui gagne avec grand plaisir je
peux vous dire que j'aurais adoré gagner
comme ça un simple et malheureusement ça
tombe sur souffle qu'est ce que j'aurais
été content j'en aurais parlé tout le
temps mais souffre elle est beaucoup
plus sympa là ils m'ont pas un petit peu
moi je pense que j'en étais lourd par
rapport à ça souffle mais d'une lourdeur
dans l'incroyable voilà mais ahmad c'est
toi qui qui qui gagne bravo bravo pour
cela voilà
c'est plutôt qu'ils jouent a
conquis le monde soit reste d'abord sens
quand
on sait que se vendent présentement
c'est le somment le choc gratuit aussi
c'est pour ça que j'aime à pleurer non
plus sur mon sort
alors tu as de la halle à prague il a
quatre et demi en battant du waf est
donc en fait
il faudrait que pour que je pense que je
gagne un sable par rapport à
prennent date devant enfin le forez ce
week-end 3-0 sur deux et que prague bat
et si bien qu de mathieu blanc et le bat
en plus de bartoli n'a pas beaucoup de
chance
pas beaucoup de chance
alors du coup du conte du coup on est
d'amener scène c'est ce qu'on attend bon
ça bouge pas trop mais en tout cas vous
voyez qu'il y avait une belle pression
on victoire de modeste de ce tout fait
mais il charrie quand même par rapport à
son à son petit prague la note qui me
charrient comme un nom je suis
moyennement d'accord avec ce qui vient
de me faire là à l'instant
normalement oui mais là il commence à
déconner à mon contact je pense que j'ai
une très mauvaise influence et du coup
du coup ils charrient comme j'aurais pu
le faire
du coup ou un gros pressing et quand on
parle d'un seul on peut peut-être aller
voir justement voie de presse la coller
à duda avec les noirs est ce que c'est
possible
c'est rien du tout non
c'est plate issime haut en bas mais
s'il fait venir ici eh ben tu es sûr de
gagner la bataille entre les deux donc
bon papa non mais moi je bouge je
souffre
je veux gagner mais avec la manière et
avec la manière voilà ça va être
ça l horreur cette position
bon je pense que c'est plus une position
peut-être pour duda que pour vendre
forrest mai mais ce qu'on préfère la
jouer côté noir ou côté blanc celle là
c'est pas facile de savoir quand vous
voyez c'est bien les gars y ait beaucoup
de pièces d'échangés et une majorité
elle dame pour la finale mais n'est pas
facile à mettre en place puisque les
pions c'est cissé mais cette si j'avance
c'est sain avec le pion baissait de
mettre en l'air et est gravement un roi
et fit d'accord bon pourquoi pas en tout
cas c'est pas c'est pas si facile cette
position
équilibrée
voilà c'est qu'ils livraient veut pas
trop où on
va voir
dans cette position
on s'endort on s'endort mon point
on ira le voir dans la finale
pouvoir plutôt un média revisite la
voilà ça fait longtemps qu'on n'est pas
allé c'est peut-être après on ira voir
manu c'est peut-être marc andrieu aussi
qu'il faudrait aller voir tout
maintenant ça se passe vraiment bien
alors des coups on a on n'a pas vu toute
cette séquence assez chaude donc on le
rappelle
visionnez prendre tout le centre avec la
corde m'améliore puisque m'améliore
enfin prévu de le reprendre par des cinq
de l'exploser peut prendre des cavaliers
brandet
et là on ne s'ouvre nous proposer des
choses ambitieuse à cavaliers au calme
et évite à jouer un tout petit mais 3
qui est aussi ce normal vraiment on
garde le quart des sondés 5 fortement et
qui avait lieu car maintenant je demande
un petit peu pourquoi on a joué b3 de
manière
si hâtive et cavaliers calme était un
peu plus de pression
tour 8 fou mais de ça d'accord
cavaliers à 5
cette fois-ci pression sur le coup c'est
4 et par rayon laser sur le pion b3
cavalier e 5 d'accord pense que l'idée
là de visite c'est que tu peux pas
vraiment prendre souffre le foot c'est
quatre ans tu peux mais c'est pas génial
je pense ouais j'aurais pu comprendre je
pense et des dessins coup d'essai 5 ou
même voir les deux oui ce sera un des
cinq ans les problèmes sont peut-être
fou quand même ouais c'est ça
ça ferait
ça ferait mal cette histoire donc du
coup
du coup toc toc toc cavaliers 5,6 is a
été joué
il est sous pression il ya des mecs
trois coups logique avec peut-être le
fait de vouloir amener la tour aussi là
où ça se passe m6
c'est ma chef si ça très très choquant
même si de mourir ça voyez un sou nous a
dit qu'ils n'avaient pas qu'on vous le
pion au fc est ce que tu dirais que
c'est une structure la pâte ou parle du
coup
non maintenant c'est à lui pas touché et
très solide ce qui est solide il aurait
pas
touche il joue comme on a trop
souvent la cause j'ai réussi à trouver
parce que dans le châtier vu un petit
indice et du cou donc j'ai rarement joué
contre pas touche en plus j'ai joué une
fois mais sur un blitz et d'ailleurs
et d'ailleurs ça a fait nul 1-1 pas
touche pas touché il avait joué il avait
joué souligne j'avais essayé j'avais
pris des risques et ça a été mon stouff
mais après ils m'avaient
égaliser et un petit changement de gamme
et si bien qu il prépare nos donc je
veux m
visite m'hamed voilà parce qu'on avait
clairement autant en profiter comme dit
arnaud voilà ça paraît logique
lundi ce que tu as eue sur pas tous
j'ai vu pire aux pierrots et et je
savais que ça pouvait lire aux barbots
et des maîtres qui s'appelle plus
j'aurai luge de ré trash
j'ai pensé à un pierre petit qu'une eau
du nord n'a france mais et ça fait pas
être sain avec toi tu vois comme
proximité plus je connais très bien
donc du coup par élimination est ce
qu'il ya un autre tiers mêlée ça
marchait pas non plus voilà est en fait
pire c'est pas mal comme prénom pourrait
admettre aux échecs en fait je suis pas
ce que tu en penses tout mais je me sens
fier c'est le prénom qui a amené le plus
de mettre en france et c'est une info
pierre bel et bien eu du culot ça avait
des gas pierre barbot ouais ça fait
quand même déjà
admettre en france sur un prénom
la date de fin mai mais j'ai un son
qu'on
attend non ça marche pas
sebha
l'un des plus froids
et pas tout ce qui lui est c'est moi le
pire des
[Rires]
deux chambres c'est marrant c'est
marrant tu aimes bien démarré mais 2,9
et que le pire se sont arrêtés que
pierre barbossa le maire pierre des
corps était très pénible mais mais c'est
loin
c'est loin d'être le cas
dit que c'est loin d'être le cas quand
même on n'est pas obligé d'être de bonne
foi un ces panneaux
ainsi quasiment 20 m
et quand il sera grand maître
le meilleur bête
et du coup la structure donc voilà on
s'est arrêté net parce que c'est moche
de jouer comme ça mais il a considéré
mariage que le cavaliere cinq années
trop pénible voilà pourquoi il a fait ça
cavaliers detroit pour aller chercher
d'autres cases avec ce cavalier
ou f-16 et la vie disent ils travaillent
autour d'eux ils se précipitent pas il
va mettre sa tour vraisemblablement ou
ses sept tours 1 c'est fait un v6 pour
contrôler cette case mais il est un
point faible en ses 6 pi quid de ce
cavalier à 5 soit je prends mais ce
cavalier j'en ai besoin aux blocs et le
pion le pion isoler puis j'ai pas envie
de mettre mes pièces moche ou c'est un
coup malin quand même fou c'est un un
coup à la soupe en bullet pas ce que
vous en pensez mais c'est tout c'est
tout toi ça ou c'est un ouais ça
ressemble à une petite fourberie tu
prépares tu on vous prend à chis à un
moment et là où c'est un tu fais sans
mots étrangers des pièces et après tu
nous déglingue ça il faut être vicieux
donc tout ça évidemment
en tout cas ce qu'on peut vous dire
c'est qu'il ya une réorganisation des
pièces blanches et commence à être dans
le même objectif parce qu'il ya eu un
petit indice de laissés par l'adversaire
qui est l'affaiblissement de la position
du roi noir et du coup main ils eussent
cavaliers qui s'est placée mine de rien
pour pour la proximité je pars avec des
cavaliers preuve ses ventes ul les tours
aussi son nul à la dame préalablement
cavaliers 101 5 dès maintenant des 3 et
le foot c'est 4 qui par rayon laser
regarder les pièces elle pèse ouvert je
me suis amusé l'asu fin j'ai fait de la
flèche verte voilà tout fonctionnait
bien au niveau de la flèche me suis dit
on voit tout ce qu'on aime dessiner
la flèche bleue bref je fais un peu ce
que je veux voilà et
donc on aime à ces critères amadeus
demande à ma secrétaire
mon mail
c'est bon à souhait de la voir mon petit
mail
ouais pas touche film avait échoué c'est
vrai que je me rappelle mon ami
l'ouverture jeune homme a avoué j'avais
essayé de tu vois le d'envoyer pas
touché il m'avait jamais vraiment le
truc le plus solide qu'on ouvertures
d'obama et qu il a
il est pas là pour rigoler patoucha n'y
a pas envie de
faire et de cabanes quoi tu vois il paie
un petit
parc ou de la cabane comme toi soupe
c'est pas son style c'est le vrai
château fort le château fort c'est bien
mieux voilà
[Musique]
s'il différents tours aussi joué par
m'hamed coût des deux on améliore on
améliore en amélior franchement minit
fait une jolie partiez il ya juste un
peu étonnamment parce que ça partiez est
vraiment très construit non par les deux
parties d'école aujourd'hui vous avez
plusieurs je trouve que celle de vie dit
il ressemble avec vraiment une raison de
pièces un jeu sur l'amélioration des
pièces restriction des pièces adverse
mais je comprends juste pas son temps
voilà alors il a dû voir une variante
amant hyper complexe et perdre du temps
là dessus mais
ça commence à être être un tout petit
peu critique pour la suite de la partie
d'avoir moins mieux dans un milieu de
jeu un peu complexe alors là il ya eu
les changes du cavalier à 5 contre le
fou ces quatre paires de vous présente
chez noir
mais attention il ya beaucoup de
l'espace chez les blancs mais on peut
s'attendre sans doute afu c3 de la part
de
petits fous ces 3 ou alors est ce qu'ils
ont peut on peut s'enflammer ou pas
est-ce qu'on peut s'enflammer
il ya le coup n'importe quoi autrement
il vous prend ainsi si je trouve qu'ils
se regardent
programme qui s'avoue sourire tout le
temps
mais il va me prendre
dans ses positions c'est le tout va
regarder tout le temps mais vie dit
alors c'est un joueur qui recule très
très bien extrêmement bien mais c'est
pas un joueur qui va partir en belin 6
voir un clair s'il n'y est pas c'est la
puce ion le tu vois alors que
mammadyarov philippe plus grand bol pour
le coup non mais ses chances ont pris
1,6 généralement quand un vent d'attac
n'aime pas trop qu'on attaque et du coup
j'ai envie de dire que
mamediarov doit pas forcément être
content de ma position contre ville dit
oui ce fut attaquée non c'est vraiment
donc vous pouvez acheter 5 ou qu'ils
sauvegardent clairement donc on va
essayer de calculer un peu ce qui se
passe ou prou en chine japon russie ce
qu'avaient les problèmes 6 à peut-être
c'est de bouger des pièces justice
ajoute pour montrer au rouge enfin
parce qu'après ça c'est foutu parce que
vous voyez la tour et menaçait donc je
regagne ma mauvaise ça et ça on en avait
déjà mangé une pièce et de pions pour un
tour enfin une qualité et de pions pour
pour les pièces et en plus en plus sain
et l'apport qui peut arriver aussi
shakhtar la diffusion verte
j'aime bien le verbe
du coup et saufs sur sur la bouffe
labour conserver à vendre
mais sinon j'aime bien le faire alors du
coup sur coup en jeu six ont peut-être
imaginer d'un point d'écart à la place
[Musique]
donc du coup ouais enfin ont fait fort
fois à chis
avec l'intention de provoquer g à chis
mais il fait d'un prendre quatre et là
j'avais une idée se trouve
qui marche pas
j'ai oublié
m520 g4 sommes là c'est vraiment car les
problèmes 6
avec
[Musique]
massy peut-être enfin faut vérifier en
tout cas
c'est à deux doigts oui oui car un titre
c'est ce que je me garde et à l'heure
donc non ça marche pas du tout sous
emprise
non
là là là on cherche absolument tactiques
initiaux on a encore du pressing
mal aussi mais
[Musique]
je peux jouer juste cavaliers déjà
cavaliers sais pas si bête mais
cavaliers ou
cavaliers g3 par exemple ce que je peux
je mets ça pour ramener du monde à la
fête
si tu prends le 2 tu manges du cavalier
ça vous êtes on prend un tour très au
point que je voulais faire au début
cette cabale hsa j'ai pas été félicité
chaudement par la mare de l'évaluation
je vais gagner cette case
pour continuer à bâtir quelque chose de
concret on sent qu'il ya quelque chose
de vraiment deux de plus pour cent
damages et 49,5 c'est dommage
tf6 d'un prend cette fois
[Musique]
balladur pas facile en tout cas de
concrétiser ici
chez food et de autrement et les fous
ces trois mais c'est lent des doutes sur
le retour des 8
à foued cas pour garder la main en fait
pas si bête peut-être
je garde la main mais c'est un peu
dommage
d'avoir donné
le pion des quatre contrats schiste
puisque j'ai pas grandement tuer le roi
adverse
du coup peut-être pas besoin sur
cavalier e set sous de de s'enflammer
avec vous prend à chis on peut peut-être
joué cette position plus simplement oui
est ce que je fous ces trois cadres et
skoda fabia mais on essaie de regarder
vous prend macheist donc ça coûte du
temps encore un visite qui est en train
de vérifier cela il vous de la vue d'un
prendre des cadres c'est certain et là
on a vu que bon on n'avait pas
grandement améliorée mais c'est pas
facile
ce qui se passe dans la tête du joueur
la visite c'est qu'il a poussé trois qui
l'avions en deux dont un millier de
calcul complexe comprend à chis et
du coup de voir est ce que cette
position là d'un premier sentiment que
vous ferez fouet f4 c'est anormal de
toute façon est-ce que c'est mieux ça
ou la variante avec pouces et 3 et là
c'est encore autre chose où ça on voit
semblablement ça parce que j'ai un
centre et tout ça mais c'est pas c'est
pas si simple
on
va bien voilà
la décision du joueur à niamey ça a pas
de facile parce que
c'est vraiment une position déséquilibré
à mon avis c'est une bonne position pour
supplanter par le relief dans les
complications
vite mais quand y'a rien de concret
tous les voies favorite watchou faut
voir des phoques n'y a rien de concret
et ben tu cherches tu cherches tu
cherches que et jeudi par être mal
autant et qui finit des fois par balance
un fou quand le dr
cas bien sûr visiteurs favori dans cette
partie 1 mais
là c'est vraiment une bonne une bonne
position pour se faire retourner
s'appelait un grand moment qu'on n'est
pas allé voir magnus
après avoir pesé le petit marc andré
qu'on n'a pas été voir depuis un moment
alors là on a été vraiment on avait vu
le gars c4 qui était le changement
structurel attendu des français mais
français et la manyu sylla d'essayer de
travailler
sur quasiment chaque dame à 6
etc c'est vraiment intéressant ce coup
parce que on a dit il faut faire jouer
les cases blanches et tout ça el haski
hallucinant c'est la décision prise mais
n'a pas trouvé mieux 1 par park à wana
qui a décidé de verser 5 mais du coup il
a il a fait un gruyère sur 15 blanche on
voit bien et 5 juillet race humaine
c'est bien
simplement
il ya peut-être finir par un plus un
magnus
voyez une menace un structurellement
parlant
l'âge des cinq ça serait vraiment une
bonne chose pour gagner les cases
blanches
je sais pas
a pas mieux que ce qui s'est passé ces
quatre décès bc damas six un super coup
un souffle
où il joue simple
et
il a fait ce que tu voulais faire tout à
l'heure en mieux encore j'ai
l'impression puisque il a réussi à faire
bouger tout à l'heure regardez avec se
trouve appelez vous on a regardé ses
cadres et regarder pousser 6 hélas ce
qui est fort avec manu c'est qu'il a
forcé un peu les éléments qui ses
caprices et 4
et maintenant
maintenant j'attends une option blanc on
te faire jouer sur noir
et du coup j'ai tout toutes les cases là
qui sont affaiblis l'aller il veut se
régaler des cases voudrait aussi un
mensonge on s'en fout bon il ya un
problème quand même c'est ce fameux tour
bien qu'on a déjà regardé plusieurs fois
stouff
type pré mal au fion baisse est donc
faut peut-être faire quelque chose dans
cette position ce qu'un double menace
tomber un ou des 5
donc je sais pas comment il a prévu de
gérer les deux en même temps
notre ami magnus
c'est quoi le si je fais pousser si cela
en fusils jeu presque tentés de laisser
tomber mon bon cheval
fois c'est
bah ouais je sais pas tu vas aller et 6
ie6 est fou des sacs mettre un petit
blocus sur le case blanche pour
commencer
je vais avoir des conventions donc
poussé 6 je vais bars tout est là mais
il m'empêche de jouer les cinq premières
choses de pet
hommage et deux choix est-ce que je joue
cavalier d2
puisque je vous tournez un
je sais pas si je fais fausse route mais
j'ai peur de b5 est ce que c'est vrai
que maintenant et mais ça marche pas il
ya ses preuves et 6 maintenant tu la
joues et
des 5 auquel jouent qu'à aider de alors
ok donc on va dire que quatre jeux
partout des cinq pour empêcher cavale et
c'était 4 hockey est maintenant tour
bien
et l'a peut-être l'udc ou alors tu vas
jeu vouloir votre tour b 6e madame com
faire suer
[Musique]
6e 6 3 6 2 à 8 jeunes voleurs contre
damas
c'est pour ça que peut-être à quatre
dames à 5 non mais c'est pour ça que je
regrette peut-être même sous ne pas voir
c'est si c est ce que tu prenais de
cesser la première question tour bien
est ce que tu peux les prêtres permettre
de prendre là c'est pas si sûr quand
même la prise prise dames cécile
ouais alors il faut faire attention
juste je peux peut-être intercalé c'est
pas sûr du tout d'un petit tour b61
bryan adams et qu'as tu me diras
elles vont tu restes avec beaucoup de
choses en l'air comme dans ces histoires
je vais en
jeu joue donc au premier ou trois je
voulais prendre trois points
d'inquiétude
dalhausser six dames c'est si c'est ce
que je te laisse pas prendre f3 non j'ai
pas trop envie
alors du coup est ce que je fous des
deux
puisque je vous revois gènes de simples
roi g2 comme madame je préférerais le
fasse autre chose
si j'ai pensé pour l'instant c'est pas
trop grave au pire j'ai tourné 6,6 des
choses comme ça
j'ai un peu du mal à
m'en fous
s'il souffre
les places vont se faire sentir c'est
toujours le jeu de ses positions
déséquilibré chacun a son objectif il
faut faire très attention dans les deux
cas
alors c'est 5 ce qui est marrant c'est
que magnus à jouer plus et 6
et du coup on va avoir le droit à mon
avis à tour b 1
on est à peu près sûr avec souffre
maintenant puisqu'on a regardé un peu la
variante qu'il ne donnera pas son fou
donc tourbains va être jouée
vraisemblablement par par kawa n'a pas
besoin de
d'enlever ce cavalier f3 alors une idée
mais ça peut plaire il
c'est une idée un ouais bon tout cela
n'est pas encore touché la pièce mais ça
aurait été de jeu bessac oui metz mais
lui sait que si si c'est assez plaisant
parce que ça fait partie des
prises d'investisseurs et d'abaisser
ouais c'est pas illogique du tout
mais ça semble un peu cher mais mme
bessette
bas je veux c'est de manger froid et du
ve
je veux jouer damas cinq là
ma présence je voudrais trop d'options
mais c'est
ce qu'on a et très peur maintenant je
suis pas sûr que tu puisses manger là
tu peux
l'option b est très fort
mais
peut-être tonton idem paraît bonne
stouff n'était pas obligé de jouer d'un
bébé ça tout de suite
alors ça a été joué un fou ces six tours
bien de fabiano étant un cadre de tout à
l'heure mais mieux s'il n'a pas osé m'a
lancé
dans quoi investit ce b5 pas dans la
case à 5,1 encore tourbe et si
damas a cafouillé donc enfin tu vas être
obligé d'avoir soif d'amour assez à 3 8
mai
est peut-être en légère difficulté comme
moi je sais pas j'ai la position est
difficile à évaluer mais j'aime bien
regarder juste on court on regarde tous
films proposés b5 si on prends mes 6
et l'a peut-être tu attends un petit peu
tu joues food et 5,7 ou
4,4 à fouday 5 x 4 et le bien
même bien
à chaque fois qu'on pose un coude à
courber le monde va ça m'énerve c'est
votre pique nique
c'est moi tranquille non mais fort gagne
apparemment assez vite le plan b si ce
n'était pas si facile quoi il croit que
le chat
il s'est converti au pôle emploi
sur du boulot kevin aussi je pense que
tu veux trouver quelque chose
c'est bon ça délire bien
sonnés l'air bien ce qu'ont à l'oeuf à
zéro dans le chat pour nous aider
ouais photo ap 01
01 c'est vraiment une ancienne version
ok du coup c'est parce qu'il s'est passé
donc tombé à 4 petits plus blanc que
compensé
on va voir tourner si cela est compensé
par se fout pas une mais le nul cette
position encore jouable comme on joue on
se pose des questions comment on joue
après avec des blancs
oui on fait toujours b6 et après on va
faire naviguer le cavalier un petit peu
souffle
bonne question
il faudrait pas mal placé de dire ok je
fais h4
ouais
j'ai enfin trouvé une idée après pour
faire mal ça et je travaille ce pion là
mettre tout sur le pion fin même là
si je peux même
par la spirale
je levin en tourbe et 6 pour la coller à
la dame adverse
bien envie de travailler
jeu
tombé 6 ch 4 jeunes bien tombé six dames
bouge h4h trucks et
a321 anciennes
perdu un instant je crois
je suis là à
persuadé que je fais un instant j'ai
peur j'ai toujours là toujours là du
coup on est au top on passe à une autre
petite position souvent le line up de
magnus mais ce qu'on vend le petit mac
andries tac donc on avait vu la partie
des rig asie
alors
petit plus ça c'était ok position tout à
leur
tour huit cavaliers hkd par les souffles
et
il a
f5 un jour mais
c'est quand même un peu naïve de
l'apparat de la part des blancs et 3
parce que
cavalier problème 5e 3 c'était une
possibilité
mais là il a enlevé son fou et du coup
ils se retrouvent sous cavaliers h4 avec
la menace g5 je crois que notre ami ron
vos gueules là
il a oublié et du coup maintenant ils se
retrouvent qui est particulièrement anti
position parce que ça fait un gros trou
bah tant mieux pour marc-andré mes
cadres joli coup j'ai l'impression parce
que il y monte directement cette case le
cadre du coup il vient taper le cas et
c3 qui
en faible très bien joué
tous rêvent de est donc là il est parti
pour souffrir l'ami google et et
l'histoire c'est que c'est de 15,5 à
chaque fois maintenant le rêve 6 donc il
est beaucoup mieux voilà il a joué
directement j'avais pas vu aurait pu
attendre aussi cavalier 1 à 5 d'un
voilier détroit il va sûrement laisser
son fou en bécane
pour se faire prendre et apprend b et on
pourra créer la case
croix ou c4eva marquer quelque chose
depuis le début de partie il cavale
était resté en mai 8 il enfin bouger
avec l'avarié
17-17 mon une erreur je sais pas on a on
est quand même plutôt pas maquillée
promet carte a été jouée je pense que la
position était très difficile pour le
joueur blanc en pratique cavaliers b un
clan ben ali et bs6
d'âme des uns ce qu'on peut déjà dire
c'est que marc andré qui a le double du
temps de l'adversaire il a une position
normand à deux résultats une position
normalement en jouant à son niveau il va
en faire souffrir un adversaire puisque
il a aucune faiblesse tout fait il ya
sur deux et un meilleur jeu de pièces
donc c'est dur un
mois c'est que moi j'avais beaucoup
beaucoup de noirs et tient
bon
même un coup comme avec benfica bâle et
2,6 et bien f 5,6 km leucate je me vient
aussi ça
la plage de jouer cavalier seul mais
très bonne position je pense que marc
andré a peu peut très bien gagner des
positions ce serait quand même
incroyable la réaction sur tournoi comme
ça surtout qui nous avait déjà fait un
quelque chose
du style en parlait en début de tournoi
quand il était un peu mal après il est
devenu très mal dans le tournoi est là
on est un peu un but triste pour lui
parce que on est en français on est
supporters d'un jeune prodige comme
marc-andré et du coup ils étaient en
train de de oued de s'écrouler un petit
peu en termes de résultats mais on l'a
senti un moment revenir en terme de
qualité de jeu et ouais ça a été très
très diesel mais maintenant qu'il est en
confiance bas il joue juste très bien
voilà il n'y a pas de pas de problème
est
aussi oui on doit aller voir visite
excuse moi je te coupe à aller là c'est
parti ces prix ton truc
vue nous à la vague sans briser les
pièces alors hier en direct on y va
directement à partie
au caire on avait dit que la pression
pouvait se retourner mais la visite
c'est un super joueur mais là à
moi qu'ils nous fassent mentir avec les
vu un super truc je vais vous mettre les
calmes mais là c'est juste c'est parti
on y est
c'est ouf parce que ça on en a parlé
tout à l'heure à la règle même nous on a
trouvé enfin c'est vraiment pas l'air
compliqué comme g4 onf les îles à sion
et comment dire ça ressemble à une
fourchette quoi
cette attaque a fait fourchette d'amd 4
des français
juste incroyable donc fois çi 100 m
haies
dames décade pour nous c'était c'était
assez logique aussi c'est bizarre
l'ordinaire d'ailleurs 10 n'est pas
d'amener 4 je vais mettre un instant
pour le coup qui le voyaient
kg 6 non mesdames des cartons et on
l'avait donné et on avait donné en plus
on récence touffu f4 finalement qui
semblait le coup la situation
mesdames g4 qui était un temps chaud si
en plus tu vois ce qui est ce qui est
bizarre c'est que je dis adam g cap
désolé sookie afp cinq je peux pas
proposer ça donc que le match se
présente sa dernière
j'estime avoir été très malin d'avoir
imposé une amende les 4 mais là à ce
niveau là c'est parce que sans un coup
quoi
les jours il a quand même de 1730
[Musique]
non mais en plus il avait une grosse
partie je vous rappelle qu'on a dit il
avec une partie des écoles j'ai juste
par contre il prend trop de temps ça
peut lui amener à un moment
voilà dès demain apprécié de se faire
retourner mais là mais il n'a même pas
eu le temps de se faire retourner que il
a déjà une gaffe énorme en fait oublier
il a dû voit un autre coup pour qu'ils
oublient rsa qui la lui être obnubilé
par un autre coup
qu'est-ce qu'il a regardé ici
j'avais 6 ou cavaler g6 maintenant c'est
pas possible avec la vallée problème si
ce
n'en fout g6 il ya toujours eu six donc
la regarder kg 6
kg si ça perd tout de suite à kiev n'ont
peut-être sa patte il a peut-être
calculé ça me remonte en souffre et du
coup il a regardé sa voix là et ça gagne
tout de suite la dame est en l'air il il
est devant un échiquier il en tilt dans
la
tête
il est pas content vide et un
branchement ça fait de la peine
voilà c'est en fait pour un joueur comme
ça c'est la honte parce que c'est pas
c'est pas une histoire de honte mais
c'est c'est par rapport à lui même il
est fâché quoi si vous voulez parce que
dans son canapé à l'aveuglent bas il
résout des problèmes
dix mille fois plus dur que cela si on
lui dit
même sur dame d'angers 4 quel est le
coût de regarde comme ça et ils m'ont
105 que tu me fais trouver là c'est
c'est une gaffe
voilà c'est des joueurs amateurs des x
1500 qui ne sont pas contents de 2
de faire ce genre de gaffes et c'est
tout à fait compréhensible
là il ya eu un manque de vérification il
s'est laissé
il a oublié incroyable c'est extrêmement
rare alors c'est la fin de tournoi donc
c'est normal qu'ils aient plus de gars
mais il a gaffé garde mais là dans une
position
visuellement compliqué mais le coup est
très simple le coup est très simple ça
peut arriver à mon tailleur d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure je les commande et julia
maintenant il ya eu 5 mai dans une
partie au niveau qu'en joue son coup on
est sûr hélas oui voilà c'est assez
dramatique quand vous voyez à l'écran
c'est inacceptable
il est possible qu'ils serrent la main
ici parce qu a pas de coups
c'est juste une pièce quoi ça va quand
même l'impression
ou alors ils n'avaient vu il comptait
quand même faire cavalier m6 c'est
possible qu'il écrit qu'il ait vu
cavaliers f6 d'ahmed six
tours aussi soit aussi sourd aux six
objets
oui vas y vas moi on est je pense un
mythe est-ce que tu pronostique yves a
acquis la monade moi je pense qu'il
abandonna stouff
il peut plus jouer un coup il y va être
paralysé là
il ya plus de coups sérieux
on en croit pas ses yeux si vous voulez
un conduit très serrée entre ces voix là
c'est trop
ouais c'est tellement évident en fait tu
assez évident en fait sans un coup quoi
servez-vous et m6 nous a mille cinq
cents lots on le rate on va s'en vouloir
mais la crue quelque chose si tu veux
juste pour
avec m6 gagne la dame quoi ils
n'appellent pas totalement ignoré m5000
avait vu quelque chose contre ou alors
il a raté cinq skype 5 voyez comment
elle a été la situation c'est lui qui
met la pression il avait décidé de faire
cavalier f6 des idées de faire d'un
projet set c'était les deux idées et f5
ça partout sa contre attaque donc ça
vous l'avez vu en plus à contrôler du
coup gros coup dur la paille aïe aïe on
a un coût non mais c'est l'horreur je
suis je fais ça en partie lente je suis
fou furieux après moi même alors un
joueur de cette qualité là comme visite
bakhit et
c'est un peu comme si ce problème est dû
à un match du couloir
est en partie non en partie lente donc
pivi dit s'il faisait un gros tournoi il
avait six points c'est un tournoi qui
est très difficile
à mon année senti qu'il était un peu en
ouais ouais était en surchauffe un petit
peu puisque et quand même fait un gros
tournant attendait pas à ce niveau mais
mais c'est possible et du coup bah là il
doit il doit pas être loin d'abandon
est-ce que amadeus à une question avant
que avant qu'on parte en partant pub
donc pas mal
sur sa triste partie 2-2 de visite
franchement c'est un peu de la peine de
le voir comme un chéquier la
cemac compact pompe une pub tant qu'il
n'y a pas eu le coup de visite ou
l'abandon ce qu'il laisse
on est obligé quoi on a obligé mais je
pense que là le coup est terrible c'est
quand même relativement rare de voir ça
en partie nantes
voilà c'est impossible web en fait
j'avais repris tu sais il y avait eu des
j'ai fait une petite vidéo youtube sur
l'île sur les gaffes souffre et du coup
j'avais repris la gaffe de
deguire et
enfin grands maîtres de 1600
complètement gagnant contre contre guiry
dame d'opinion contre dame et il se
prend mal tu c'est un match super météo
au championnat oui j'oubliais tu te
rappelles hallucinant mais bon blitz
tout arrive si vous voulez on a vu tous
les meilleurs joueurs du monde donner
leurs dames etc mais en partie nantes
avec il avait incarné entre un quart
d'heure et 20 minutes visite à ce moment
là c'est juste pas possible il n'ya pas
de ya pas de cours
il va peut-être fait père et
là je pense qu'il a envie de continuer
mais s'est pas construite et sa dame
aux camélias même si je sais pas mais il
ya vraiment plus de coups
même mamediarov il s'est levé longtemps
parce que c'est toujours un peu comme ça
c'est un peu gênant même pour me dire en
face à biarritz
il est gêné par rapport à la après alizé
il n'arrive même pas regardé biblique
dans les yeux véritablement parce que
[Musique]
parce qu'à la fois c'est rigolo et
comprend la détresse du mec aussi ça lui
arrive et des trucs mais il dit mais
c'est incroyable mec joue bien un +6 et
il sait qu il se dépeint comme un tout
petit peu marcher dessus hein
ma meilleure offre dans cette partie on
voit que visitent envoyé quoi et du coup
ma vie dit il lui reste une minute il
sait pas quoi jouer et
et du coup la gamme est telle que c'est
un traumatisme mais je sais pas s'il va
réussir à jouer parce qu'il n'ya rien à
jouer il ya juste works et ouais rien à
jouer c'est l'horreur
mais même il ya fille sait pas trop mais
c'est pas trop ce qui va se passer mais
ok c'est juste du web c'est du rarement
vu mais de temps en temps voilà c'est ce
qu'on dit aux échecs c'est pas pour rien
qu'on verse vérifications
mais il sait plus quoi jouer et la
dizaine de gâcher une très très belle
partie parce que quand même il gagner
cette partie il était quand même hyper
chaud à l'idée ce n'est pas impossible
au vu de la position
tu penses que la moins nous pas
je pense qu'il va abandonner
je pensais ça c'est la haine j'ai vu je
mets en direct un fou pranger cette
voie là où pranger sense ok bah c'est
jouer on va partir en pub sur ce coup là
mais sachez que ça n'a pas changé la
face du monde mamediarov tout tout
croquer minutes à toutes ces pièces en
l'air et
voilà on vient d'assister à [ __ ]
angers7 mais la position on va partir
d'un prince valiant - dames francs
voilà et après cela bientôt il y aura
abandon
voilà
donc qui jouent sur la peur et crémants
pour jouer 15 coups salut générique est
le françois
et
arrive pile pour la pub donc on va on va
on va vous laisser à leur route pour
titan starcraft cavaliers tech comme tu
disais et vas y avait d'armes prend
cavaliers qui ne gagnait pas la dame et
qui perdent une pièce à la place et adam
rester en l'air en plus et le fou aussi
bref grâce offre donc ce n'était pas
satisfaisant mais fou pranger ça ne
l'est pas non plus ça va être bientôt
l'abandon pour 8 je sais même pas s'il
va tenir la bulle
sera-t-il toujours vivant après la pub
sur l'échiquier et bien sûr allez on
envoie la pub on vous dit à tout de
suite a tout de suite
[Musique]
on
à
là
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et on est reparti avec
un vent de forêts ce qui est plutôt pas
mal c'est ce que tu m'a avoué pendant la
pause 9 toof oui dois je dois l'avouer
un canton et quand on est dominé
dans le pari il faut le dire alors du
coup ma bonne forme ce qui est en train
de prendre l'aventage sur sur duda
ça sent le petit seul tout ça
donc lutter entre pendant qu'on parle et
si bien qu'au rapport ça fait nul
on peut faire un petit mot
sur la position
proche de l'abandon chez eux je suis dit
au dessus alors et si bangkok est donc
du coup toute façon c'est une partie
impression il va et bienfaits d'un
mécène le coup tout à l'heure et comment
il ya eu eu 4 directement on le tourne
et un venir un petit peu la position moi
je dis si passage de leur jugement phuc
très fine je tiens le piouf hockey sont
plus à ce moment là
mais il ya le pion bessin qui qui
sautent tourner un edin me 5 liquidation
général trouvé est ok
bon là ça fait le second non voilà on
arrive à trouver les pièces il tord à 3
nuls on est le jour où tu mangeras
forcer le trait venger les 6 et ben je
sur mambo déjà même la fina doit déjà
peut-être la bande des six mais
normalement je pense que quand même
réussi à
hilla il a vraiment facilement affaires
à faire annuler cette position je sais
pas s'il y avait une meilleure sur les
chiens
peut-être même bessette le coup j'ai
donné apparemment ce n'était pas si
c'était pas le meilleur mais c'est dur
de ne profiter il fallait laisser tomber
à se réjouir les parties de rapports
quand tu vois la partie la joue contre
kawada dans l'ouverture à récupérer les
hash 6 et là tu vois que là il faut qu
avait lieu cet été on voit qu'il a quand
même pas mal d'idées un petit peu fourbe
son style par contre maintenant il a un
style épuré stratégiquement
c'est pour ça qu'il a aussi fort
d'ailleurs parce qu'avant c'était un peu
folle et maintenant il s'est calmé il
sait tout faire quoi il est très complet
et en plus il a des idées mesquine dans
les ouvertures quoi bon ok plus des 6
penco rapporte aujourd'hui
donc me dit on peut vite fait passer
regarder on reviendra sur le poulain
après on était dans cette position il a
été aujourd'hui joseph ou progresser at
on pouvait on peut vous laisser la cam
si vous voulez
vivid vie de mohammed vi vi qui n'en
revient toujours pas voilà et ça n'a pas
changé 1 puisque regarder il se retrouve
à jouer une finale pour i ii chez pourri
voilà où il ya une pièce de moins
du coup il pourrait parce que déposer
les armes mais il préfère se battre bon
bain libre à lui un
mail à lacets du rhin là c'est dur il va
se faire raser espions en associant la
voilà bon ça va ça va être trop dur
surtout gavin ils ne regardent pas de
l'aube 7
j'ai pas regardé
non mais qu'est-ce que vous avez
aujourd'hui 2
alors je vais vous dire un truc ce n'est
que justice quand il a appris cela il
s'est dit bon gilet noir j'avais prévu
de jouer solide mais en plus de jouer
sur l'idh à la fin je vais
remettre les pendules à l'heure au
niveau des serbes et du coup je vous
ramène directement chez lui
et ça c'est complètement
complètement
calme et un avantage stoop
malheureusement ce que je disais je fais
pas trop il fallait mettre le roi et
c'était peut-être recette qui fait les
mémoires est ce que est ce que la
souffrance regarder cette position la
pause il me parlait de getac
quelqu'un pénible par les jets pour pour
couper la défense de la faune sauvage
toi
et
essayer d'aller mendier pour la foi
chrétienne
donc en plus tu as magenta menacerait
aussi on fait un gâteau
à la tour bouge de semaine du 3
et du tour d un peu de
gens regardent depuis voilà roger quatre
tours j'étais petite dame déjà
joué en fin de
3e et 4e tours 3g dans le même temps
c'est pas si clair je pense non pas de
la
capitale et tours de la
fin j'ai pas le temps de casser
le cou qui peut pas de vieux jours alors
je suis arrivé je pensais que tu étais
un mec sympa tu m'as bienvenus
du coup il faut peut-être regarder
dedans me 8,2 que d'un but 8-7 pertinent
pour essayer de faire
je prends la cour comment oued alger 6
je voulais faire
je suis venu le voilà
je fais un sale coup parce que ça
c'est nul ça mais je peux faire ça il
faut que tu fasses fouet f7 si tu veux
continuer là
le fouet et fenêtres c'est pas la même
ouais c'est vrai que ça descende
parfaitement
ouais tu peux tu peux payer pour voir
peut-être à groix schwyz
non c'est risquer un
mois donc c'est pas si facile l'histoire
on
c'est encore un petit peu un petit peu
chaud cette position
en tout cas j'essaie d'amener 8 a été
jouée à partir de ce moment là et si
j'ai pas levé 4 qu'est-ce que je joue
ouais c'est joué d'ailleurs
chaque classe je vous remettra
chacun a joué par votre corps est
jacques annaud hockey d'un seul coup
et s'il veut cette fois c'est pour qu'on
la veut dire
si la tour et passive aurait peut-être
on a des chances sans doute deux nuls
c'est quand même lui qui joue pour
gagner normalement mais c'est pas non
plus parce que moi je pensais que vous
ne pourrez s'il allait il avait gagné
tranquille et
souvenez de ce souffle réparer
l'injustice dont vous avez parlé
maladroitement dans le tchad
mais c'est pas sûr c'est pas sûr du tout
malheur aux assauts et mamediarov me dit
c'est à dire que se terminer
ma vie dit ah bon et merci à toi
néandertal est effectivement tu me
souligne on va pas aller le voir mais on
a vu la plus grosse gaffe peut-être du
trou noir
dans cette partie
entre vie vie dit emma med
alors est ce qu'on ne va pas voir 400 ça
pas mal changé on voit que la dame noire
a réussi à s'infiltrer un petit peu à
des philosophes saluer l'ex personnes
salut à vous bienvenue à vous c'est tout
ce qui nous rejoint
alors on est dans cette position car la
scène il est un pur céret millan toutes
les cases blanches tour c'est on sait
pas trop tour des huit cas et les deux
d'accord ça tourne la dame noire vient
pour voir les cases blanches f3 le coup
qu'on n'aime pas en règle générale
huawei et magnuson a directement profité
avec ce tour prend des quatre coins des
4 ou prend et d'un prend cavaliers à
valider que maintenant la qualité prend
la paire de fou et que les pions fois
faible c'est ça que cinq se crève
et puis on sent pas la porte que sous
des tours quoi maintenant elles sont pas
prêts colonne ouverte ok il y en a eu au
lendemain mais c'était dur d'aller la
chercher pour l'instant il ya le footsie
jeunes
et du coup l'impression le pressing ne
fait que commencer
et franchement d'autant plus qu'il ya
cinq minutes
il n'a pas joué mais pas facile à jouer
en pratiquant wasquehal scène c'est
quand même vraiment mon sens
ils sont bien les coups
comment il est assis il se sent bien et
garde sa façon et cela
sert il et il est facile en sont quand
même un incroyable j'adore cette
séquence à partir de ces cas tu vois on
avait senti tous les deux qu'il fallait
prendre les cases manche qu'on n'avait
pas trouvé les regards la mêlée qui nous
avait donné quand même avec damas y
échouent que c'est très élégant parce
que j'étais d'accord avec toi quand tu
as joué pouces et 6 tous les deux on a
joué sa
vie c'est les cases blanches succès lui
il arrive à trouver ce couloir
et sur ces cinq de carmona qui était
légitime
mais il a réussi encore à faire mousser
6 pour bloquer des cinq normales la
cades pas de souci et on avait trouvé un
coût qui était pas mal oui
tourbe éclats de faire quelque chose
sauf que carole un village plein veut
pas si plate pour eux c'est un j'avais
pas comprendre le coup puis bon là je le
descends donc c'est un peu bizarre il a
voulu empêcher les dames c4
la f3 basque oui il a été
bon bain en tout cas il s'est pris un
jeu il sa cuisse thématique vous voyez
par rapport à la valeur des pièces
considère qu'ils sont fous énorme plus
le pion c'est plus qu'une tour
momentanément et c'est assez vrai puis
toutes ces pièces en règle générale se
fout là est moins bien la tour peut
venir en des huit à tout moment le fou
g7 fait action de jeu il a libéré son
fouquet s est aussi
très intéressant ce pion à isoler isoler
et le fou qui est monstrueux qui sera
pas
contredit bastien est le pion passé et
la faiblesse oui il est mieux régler nos
3 me dans la pendule à cette chose qui
se passe il va être un dirigeant
financière il va et c'est marrant vous
êtes fière car c'est dans son interview
on lui a dit que ben du coup avec la
victoire devant le forez souris et quand
il était quasi sûr de gagner le tournoi
où l'allemand est ce qu'ils pensaient de
ça il a du bon gros moi je m'en fous en
fait puisqu'il a daz c'est sa propre
performance dans le pont
et est pas content d'avoir fait nul hier
contre les clans et voilà le lien entre
les ardennes il est multimillionnaire
yen + droite ni jours
mais il veut monter son vélo et il veut
gagner des parties en fait mouais mouais
maintenant il peut se permettre
il aurait plus il a des objectifs de
résultat qui est
bah c'est de tout gagner et d'avoir le
plus gros lots possibles en faisant les
meilleur parti possible il est au dessus
la mêlée même en termes d'objectifs
c'est vraiment il veut jouer comme un
dieu quoi c'est ça qui est ça qui compte
pour lui ont bien compris et est en ce
moment pour qu'ils jouent vraiment
manière limpide propre villa les noirs
ils ou s'est séparé en fait d'eux les
noirs les blancs alors qu'à ce niveau là
avant vraiment gagner avec baignoire
c'est dur bas
ils s'en fichent ils jouent aux échecs
et
berlin lui il a un peu moins bien en ce
moment et c'est
c'est son principal adversaire
l'instant on voit que malheureusement il
peut l'inquiéter on voit pas le candidat
[Musique]
se dégage est particulièrement
alors pourquoi pas mais elle pourquoi
pas un fear où déjà on va pas irriguées
isi mais dans les top players on a du
mal à voir qui
qui va le climat le
le comment dirais-je le gène est
peut-être un petit être un petit firoud
mais à partir ou pour l'instant tu tiens
ghazi bon il est hyper fort ils perdent
tout ça mais bon là même le même âge que
fuir ou
et firent août 2008 son vélo ça fait mal
quand même hein
parce qu'il a fait dans le tourment
d'autres notamment au grand prix aux
championnats d'europe par équipes juste
monstrueux froissée c'est une machine à
battre les 26 57
dans le chat on voit qu'il ya quelques
supporters soient des français soit de
wesley so soit digne irène mais oui
aujourd'hui franchement 2
pour l'instant car on se sait pas ce qui
va gagner c'est pas encore dit
mais c'est du rhin
est-ce que ça a évolué
duda il y avait une grosse décision à
prendre il faut qu'on aille voir la main
sur place de jiri est-ce que c'est
toujours une une master class gris ou
pas alors
qu'est ce que ça donne
gkd à tour eu un tour ou un jouet est ce
que c'était bien ce tour et là ben moi
je pensais qu'il avait des rêves il y
avait des hommes des deux caves l art
for non
parce que je passe d'un problème de 1 et
d'apprendre est ce que c'est
bref à vous ces quatre
étaient toujours dans ma vie at il
choisi
donc voir un peu ce qui se passe
est-ce qu'il est serein duda
ça a l'air d'aller il va venir je pense
qu'il va venir ça nul doute datura et va
m'enlever le somment de la bouche
ça c'est pas fou avait pas bien
bienvenue à toi l'éolien c'est là
bas dans ce cas là et toutes les
qualités on adore la baisse des
champions c'est pas pour la blague en
plus froid que léon de bruxelles je
crois que c'est un restaurant c'est une
chaîne cnn
c'est vraiment léon de bruxelles en plus
est ce qu a dit léon de bruxelles
en argentine souffle non je sentais que
non mais chanter le centre xl donc il y
en a il y en a il y en a à paris on a vu
plusieurs appareils de mesdames même
mangé dans un réseau comme ça à paris
mais bon bruxelles paris envers ses à
côtés quoi sert un style aussi l'europe
et ces francophones tout ça normal mais
en argentine pas trop
tu en allemagne les ontariens en
vacances peut-être alors
c'est moi la marque de néandertal chaîne
moules frites
ils font beaucoup de fruits de mer
dire nuls ça fait nul ne dit rien je
voudrais ici et là au mois de mai de
la masterclass la régie n'a pas eu lieu
mais là qu'on ait ces mêmes nul
apparemment bien payés
alors qu'il avait un avantage
important
n'a pas réussi à convertir cet avantage
d'un bep cette
grande alliance il a joué g5 g4 et a
réussi à inverser c'est joli ça
la tendance pas réussi à profiter de son
avantage
quand il y avait un petit quelque chose
et s'est crispé visiblement pas réussi à
trouver la clé de cette position est
même pire il a
apparemment il n'a pas très bien joué
l'irie cette position il devait
normalement
assuré un casque il a intérêt parce que
là on voyait que c'était steam elle mêle
position de de fixation
c'est pas facile de vous dire comme ça
ce qu'il a vraiment raté mais on voit
qu'il avait une position de pressing et
l'a jamais réussi à gagner le pion
bécistes ouf il n'a pas
pas réussi à prouver l'avantagent dans
cette position bon qu'est de façon
structurée galles mais on voyait les
pièces étaient
étaient mieux placés dont on pensait
qu'ils allaient réussir à faire un petit
précis mythe et n'avait pas l'air
content de faire de faire nul est bon ok
c'est fait c'est fait et il nous reste
les i'm not de duda et le zaï notes
boisées note d'ailleurs ils y vont avoir
du temps fait instant fin puisque on
voit qu'il reste neuf 39 à duda sur dam
des deux donc c'est du temps
tu dis 38
sur magnus mais magnus il ya beaucoup de
temps aussi pour convertir sur sedan b 4
qui vient d'être qui vient d'être jouée
alors est-ce qu'on n'irait pas voir
si tu veux gêner c'est la cam oui c'est
passer plein de choses
allez je vous mets la cam
la mx calmes avec tous les joueurs
chaque soir à vienne j'ai bien vu que
prince n'y avait pas grand monde ça va
bien surtout qui m'apprend rien
[Musique]
ouais je peux chercher pour tout vous
dire soufi mais il rate pas une il
savait que je savais mais voulait juste
juste me narguer un petit peu
marc-andré il est presque gagnant mais
faut que je fasse gaffe dans le zag
notes boisées note c'est surtout son
adversaire qu'il est il reste de quoi
franchement ça sent bon mais il ya des
petits trucs sur son roi donc ça peut
toujours brillé
voilà l'autre peut faire un truc comme
ça mon voir glas d'un peu tout le temps
revenir en à celle du coût 100 perd un
petit peu
je crois que marc andrieu et va gagner
il m'a l'air assez écrasant un cavalier
à 4 cavale et c3 pour venir attaquer la
tour et c'est pousser le puck bêtement
là il y là il vient de damas trois c'est
mignon regarder le joli coup ça c'était
vraiment sympa revoir il a mis la
pression sur l'option b 2-1 - être une
tactique damas trois le proposant sa
dame avec l'idée de gagner celle de
l'adversaire et d'avoir le pion passé
démoniaque
cas et c3 b2
b12 gagner le pion qui est parti donc
vraiment trois coups gagnants
et maintenant il n'y a plus qu'à
convertir le gain puisque le joueur en
face d'un bail changé d'âme petite
partie de son adversaire et grosso parti
de marc andré qui qui confirme tout le
bien
compenser lui de la depuis la partie
contre
contre comment dirais-je le petit le
petit morzine
mais bon on peut dire aussi peut-être
qu'il n'avait pas eu un appariement si
facile et eu les deux une combo des deux
a pareillement difficile une mauvaise
entrée en matière au sac une dp drones 1
sur une double imprécisions alors que
compenser qu'il a été retenu le
rapidement et quand on commence un
tournoi par une défaite est pas facile
de se remettre des prêts mentalement
c'est ce qui est un petit peu manqué bon
bah je propose qu'on aille
on retourne dans le 1 puisque là alors
que dans le béa par une nulle doerig a
dit celui qui est en tête il n'ya pas de
parti de fini
stouff alors que dans le décompte
vraiment un
après dans le beckham ya quand même pas
mal de parties qui sont qui sont pas
terminées je pense mais mais c'est vrai
que les gens ont l'air de plus ce la fin
donc tu dois venir sur quatre scènes du
coup way's mills hanafi sauf si tu
penses que tu n'y a plus de coup de
véritables zain note pour caruana et du
coup c'est un peu plus excitant pour
pour tous ceux qui sont avec nous
c'est le c'est le seul qui a vraiment il
ya vraiment un gros
1 rodez nat alors du coup il ya 2 6
mondial n'aura jamais aussi surtout en
plus pour essayer de les changer les
fous de cases noires il estime
maintenant que le foot 15 noire
des noirs est beaucoup plus fort c'est
le fou de pression on le fout des cadres
c'est le fou le mauvais fou hein
et du coup je peux vous dire que ça va
durer cette partie à mon sens et qui va
le triturer
beau travail à l'aide une à deux heures
6 caruana tient son zaïna ce qui est pas
impossible les onze coups mais là on va
voir 20 minutes une vingtaine de minutes
l'hyper excitante pour qu'on voie un
petit peu ça doit vous intéresser tous
les joueurs amateurs qui est qui nous
regardent parce que il ya du matériel en
moins sur le papier ce qu'il ya une
qualité d' avance pour caruana contre un
pion mais il ya la perte de fou donc
d'abord de fou c'est john lipsky
finalement il ya un demi point qu'on a
un demi point concret en plus pour les
blancs mais le jeu de pièces noires est
tellement bon que
ben c'est pas le cas très prochainement
peut voir cette manoeuvre par exemple
l'arrivée souffre et ça va sauter il ya
des pions qui vont sauter
peut-être qu'il faudra un moment pensé
aussi ouvrir les cases blanches qui a
plusieurs plusieurs idées porte pas la
permanence vient de trouver un coup
pour changer la position il veut changer
la position parce qu'il n'aime pas mais
il donne aussi un pion
est ce qu'on le prend ses pions j'ai
envie de continuer le pressing ce que je
peux pas jouer dame e3 c'est pas fou
peut-être
moi ça me démangeait j'ai une idée mais
elle souffre ce serait trop beau dames
e3 3 h 1b et fouet froid
et c'est quoi ton était en fête à jeudi
pas
le secret le manger deux fois ci ça va
marcher
un chien pelech pour ça
[Musique]
saint paul ait autant que c'est pas fort
c'est juste le prendre tu vois déjà
c'est la problématique et voyez je
commence a essayé de m'intéresser au roi
adverse
alors comment on fait dans cette
position
si souvent je vais 4.5
d'un braquage peut-être faire tout
reprendre bagad a pas
qu'avec le fou alors ouais si elle gagne
elle pioche publié chez fo prend 1,5
mais cheyrou prend 1,5 ce qui me dérange
entre guillemets le plus c'est fou prend
1,5 ouais même temps
il faut garder les fous si on peut quand
même la paire de fou ce serait en tête
dameuse 3 tout simplement est bon je
m'en crois qu'on vous prend 25 la rend
la question c'est comment je progresse
avec les avec le noir parce que si je
mange pas sinon qu'est-ce que je fais
quoi
là privé 4 il a primé cas maintenant il
ya tout reprendre donc il a considéré
une affaire de fous allait faire
beaucoup de mal mais j'ai pas réussi
dans cette position à faire la
différence
peut-être tour promet 4 suivi deux à
trois c'est possible en fait il ya
peut-être c'est peut-être une gaffe
parce que simon pions arrivant à deux ça
va commencer à être pénible non
ouais mais attends mais à trois tours à
toi
et tu veux pas empêcher la consolidation
food et 5 à 2
donc on est en train de regarder c'est
la valorisation du pion à 3
après passé la tour les mortiers le pion
aux peut-être monter le roi
il ya une autre il ya un gain en fait je
crois avoir vu un homme bien ou f-18
ici je crois fuite il va jouer ça c'est
sûr
c'est hyper en mettre
les cannes b5
intéressant
si on prend pas s'envoyer la tour est
perdu et on va avoir deux pions passé tu
vois bien je mets un truc comme ça c'est
hyper temps
après il est truffé de ses shows ah non
en fait mais dont je peux pas mais fou 3
mois je sais
moi je préférais 3
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué vite par contre
oui c'est pas ici ah oui donc d'un
premier quart ça a été refusé par
caruana un tour prendre b4 à cause du
pion ou du foie puis les deux d'ailleurs
il a préféré faire comprendre mais
qu'at-elle donné le pion et maintenant
c'est dur
parce qu'on joue pour rien enfin la clé
le seul plan valable ici c'est l'échangé
bout de quinze noir je pense pour
essayer de tenir une nulle mais c'est
extrêmement difficile à faire
[Musique]
très très dur
ça c'est quoi il a échoué à trois
points logique parce que ça va permettre
de
éventuellement je vais fou mais ne
peut-être que du coup
[Musique]
il peut très bien toujours plus ou moins
3 rafou comprend les a318
a319 en toi de te les 3 1 ça
j'ai pas le temps mais tu veux bien être
maquillé le trou dans un fou des cinq
tout par exemple
ouais mais je perdais fois de sacrifices
pour récupérer mais c'est bon
tu as des par exemple imaginons un c'est
pas maintenant mais je vous le savent et
sacrifice de si on met le faux en d5
avec les blues noir pour compléter et
bien j'ai peur d'avoir prend des cinq
puis on prend être tombé c'est taylor ce
type lancé qui peut avancer et à bord et
un peu de courage de dire bon peut-être
mais son élection à compresser un jour
posé on se remémore
effectivement c'est sa méthode
moi je voulais en fait je reviens
je fais ça
pour taper le pion et c'est mon fou qui
va dominer le tien maintien ne rien
faire mais
houphouët cisco 1,7
c'est un peu galère l'histoire
des sacs et je me remets ça c'est vrai
en plus que je pense qu'il pourrait
tourner le film est là
mais c'est vrai dur avec l'histoire ou
des cinq à trois partenaires
je pense qu'elle est très difficile à
jouer
en fait je suis absolument convaincu que
ma news doit gagner par position je
pense que c'est madame à l'égal de son
voile et en plus un voyage qui a déconné
si un jour nous aide donc on a huit
coups à jouer encore un techno avec deux
buts de la pendule pour caruana 8ce
carte
16-12 avant de forrest a l'air d'être là
nul qu'on
supposait
les fouets petits soient achetés sur pam
oui parce que le plan avec les blancs
c'était vraiment d'échangé le foot 15
noir donc la réputation de magnus je ne
veux pas échanger vos deux cases noires
mais c'est ça en fait si jamais les fous
sont échangées et 20 les blancs sur l'a4
notamment la colonne des alors qu'ici
kem sokha se voir des fois repoussée la
gaze délicat et la part d'autres courent
ensemble a fait un gros boulot nos
temples et noir doivent garder des fous
risquez de vous perdre bloqué sur 15
noir à un moment si les pneus sont plus
là voilà il y aura toujours votre cou
pour essayer de désosser un bloqueur
est ce que l'allemagne ne veut pas jouer
fouet cet
exercice désarroi f2
pas si facile encore il ya du travail
et donc n'est pas là mais mais duda
kankossa a perdu j'ai vu ça j'ai vu ça
j'ai regardé un petit peu où ça en est
et c'était le
cd de la loire annonce avec 2,8
voilà qu'il ne reste que vous marquez
alors que vous montez à l'écart d'une
carpe est en cours voilà on a lâché du
mato seconde forest mais
voilà non c'est que ça a perdu 2
maintenant on ne va pas passer trop de
temps on va rester sur magnus on sait
aussi que on va attendre la fin 2 1 et 9
mai mc andry y avait une position très
positive mais il restait plus design ils
ont fait le leur
à l'antienne coup 40e coup c'est
peut-être un peu revenu en face on verra
ça on ira regarder mais en tout cas il a
un bon avantage une position à deux
résultats on peut lire une perdra pas
vraisemblablement et
moi je pense que ça même fini
le qe2 est complètement foutu et et le
plan b a avancé marc andré a va
probablement trop lents d'ailleurs green
cette position et et ce serait vraiment
très très bien lancé entendre un parce
qu'il a commencé la commencer un polder
il a commencé avec 1/2 / / / 5 1 sur 6
mois il avait un sur sept pardon et là
il a enchaîné nul bien nu le gain est un
autre bien derrière donc ça freine pas
mal hein van uhm 2,3 qu
en cinq parties graphiques quatre points
sur quinze et donc hegazy regagné se
tenir avant la partie
magazine qui est qui est maintenant
assuré un deuxième fois parce que j'ai
re a fait nul à donkey à gaz il a un
point et demi d'avancé sur le 2
poursuivants donc il est sûr de gagner
le tournoi même si il venait à perdre
demain contre contre marc briane donc la
regarde 80 caméras on m'appelle parce
que tu vois le nom
nous est pas possible quoi ces terribles
quoi il s'est rangé il sait très bien
qu'un stream quoi
je ne pouvais pas lui répondre
mais c'est pas vrai et il fait vraiment
exprès pour te déconcentrer ce touche à
tout je les appelais hier aussi
ça commence à être très très dur on fait
mieux si je très simple français qui
avait amené son voir comme ça comme ça
peut-être à kiev 5 mm il se met juste
pour la pression
c'est
pas ce bonjour babbitt
bisous à lui les eaux à lui est
là ouais c'est dur dur
ça fait mal en tout cas
c'est l'horaire quoi
30 secondes pour pour caruana six coups
à jouer et une position sans objectif
donc dans cette position-là votre
adversaire va tourner et tourner faire
des menaces et vous avez plus trop de
quoi jouer donc
[Musique]
problématique c'est que il sait plus
quoi faire il attend et on peut le
travail est
fini cela c'est alors qu'on a déjà
qu'est ce qui a fait renvoyer m
il peut même faire fi des cinq
maintenant je trouve par rapport à tout
à l'heure ce qu'il ya c'est cinq ans
l'air
fut des 5 c'est intéressant à ce que
j'ai toujours des cadres peut-être
voilà voire même tour processus
d'arrière oui c'était l'idée
mais le fou des cinq tours des quatre
tours france et 5 tours prend 1,4
et peut-être tour ces deux tours à 2
alors du coup on a peut-être fou des
cinq pour magnus a une idée pour france
et 5 évidemment mais là il ya peut-être
encore tour des quatre de mes lettres au
cours des cinq quand même un nom ouais
c'est ça la question le tour française
5g
tour points 4
tours cède c'était ça l'idée il aura
beau juste moi un petit message pour toi
il me demande de te dire d'essayer de
mieux aujourd'hui et après
ça si je savais la fois qu'on a joué
ensemble ce que je vais me mais en fait
c'était à fort longtemps on n'a pas joué
on n'a pas joué depuis et du coup il a
en travers et l'entrain vert
je sais que quand j'avais joué cette
partie contre lui mais ça fait vraiment
un moment était jeune pierre fallait-il
23 50 mais était quand même quand même
jeune c'était la fameuse partie où
j'allais me madam temps plein milieu le
jeu ma tour dans son camp en achats et
du coup les gens comprenaient pas
comment ma tour était arrivé dans son
camp donc un peu triste pour lui
inquiet il faudrait que je fasse une
vidéo sur cette partie quoi faire as-tu
de la ferme ta gueule pas on fait de la
plus de partout qui rétrograde pour
essayer de comprendre comment la tour a
pu arriver dans son camp ça pourrait
être intéressant voilà mais la connaît
bien celle là à chaque fois je lui en
parle bien raide me parler de ça
il ya longtemps
un peu tendre dr c2 et du coup oui
suroît g3 par exemple tour à 2 je parle
comme ça qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu'est ce
qui se passe tout cas ce qu'on voit pas
ça à l'air bien ça pourquoi ça marche
pas
ce qu'on se fait on se fait attraper je
sais pas quelle quelle astuce non celle
là souffre aide moi ce que j'étais
content avec ce tour a de bons débuts et
en fait
vraiment rate quelque chose
tour à lui à ouïr gardant leur tour à 8
j'avais vu je me tire au g7 fou mais
deux échecs et voilà
oui
on n'a rien gagné du tout donc en fait
c'est encore un petit peu de boulot donc
sur tours d2 voilà magnifié le travail
très probable 9,6 c'est super et
il va améliorer son roi presse et bim
bim bim à peu près
et en fait il considère que taiwan en
soumission totale donc à roanne a joué
le coup logique à 4 pour empêcher les
cinq fassi et la construction avec le